all right and we are
live the last word with laura cognito
and ibontis
back on that friday morning campfire
no big guess nothing to talk about she's
in the show
yeah nothing nothing to talk about
nothing at all
now i was like normally
i gotta tell you guys i gotta i gotta
figure out what order i'm gonna do this
i gotta bring our guest in but we also
got something else to talk about but
first
we got a guest in front of us here you
guys can uh listen to her she's amazing
so let's get this thing started
welcome to the last word episode 118.
i'm pumped about it yesterday so let's
welcome her to the campfire the only we
know how
see if we can make them blush i'd like
to introduce a lady who knows more about
this game than many of us will ever hope
to
she knows raid so well she can guide a
party of blueberries through anything
while jamming to the beats the whole
time this is a trusted community member
who is there to support everyone
even through the toughest of times and a
pillar
of greatness uh and yet she has so much
skill
skill she takes on encounters one-handed
just to make it a challenge
so let's welcome to the campfire the
project lead for raid secrets reddit
a hard-working undergrad someone who
will be there to
basically pull out the clutch play when
the match is on the line and the ceo of
all frogs
let's hear it for hoplite thank you guys
so much
let's get it how are you doing this
morning good
i'm good it's uh it's been a long few
days
but oh now we're doing good yeah
good sounded like you missed the weather
which is which is a good thing
of course that seemed a little crazy so
you're like hurry can't just lean to the
right come on
good to have you so finally get you to
campfire
to talk about a lot going on you know i
was lying
yeah nothing nothing important happening
at all
seriously so yeah let's talk let's talk
about how
let's talk about it like so uh obviously
you know i mean big in the community and
stuff so like
just in general you know let's start
from kind of like beginning as far as
kind of just gaming first like
what what kind of got you in gaming and
stuff like that
uh i mean so my dad was a big fan of
games going up
particularly diablo that's his favorite
series but
he had an old playstation an old
dreamcast
and so as a kid i was constantly playing
sonic adventure
pacman world and so that's kind of what
i grew up on
nice that's a that's a classic set there
a lot of classics so then from there you
kind of you just kept on with it you
know from that
that nice hey i appreciate i was gonna
say i appreciate you got the dreamcast
the playstation but
nintendo added the legend of zelda
series to your life so we are friends
now this is all i need to see
zelda is one of my all-time so that's
that is beautiful
i love that so which zelda what are your
like top couples at
zelda's like don't overthink it just
couple cocoons to pop into your head
hey so i haven't gotten to play ocarina
okay okay but uh twilight princess i
really enjoy
nice that's so loud i enjoy it but it
didn't feel like the other shoe
i don't mind though this is like a good
game
um and then skate with sword
hey no that was that was
very polarizing zelda we
nice nice very cool very cool yeah very
like i said like so many
great zeldas and i love how everyone has
that little emotional attachment to
specific one
so it's really cool to see that's
awesome that's awesome so if you ever
get a chance
okay that's one of those like i feel
like ocarina of time
ocarina however you say it i'm sure i'll
get it wrong all the time uh
it is one of those that seems like a
classic even when people go back to play
it so if there's a chance for you to
play it at some point
believe i'd like i don't have enough
time to do anything anymore either so
it's kind of hard to ask but
it is a good one but from what i've
heard of people are like ranking like
ocarina of time
twilight princess ranks really high for
a lot of people so the fact that that
one's sitting up there you're already
good to go
absolutely absolutely so eat what you
got
so i wanted to ask how the journey into
like
raid secrets kind of come and be could
becoming a project lead there
and this is like the destiny raid
secrets reddit if you guys have ever
seen that before which if you've ever
looked up any
like guides trying to track like the
most current crazy puzzle
that's going on it's all in there so how
did you get involved and what kind of
what drew you to that to kind of really
get involved in that group and community
so it was watching streams basking
season
5. i think
um and
[Music]
it was in the middle of the tsunami
forest puzzle
and they were struggling with it and i'm
like
okay i kind of want to help so i joined
the discord i'm hanging out with them
i better say help them get through it
then iob labs comes around
and there was so many different ideas
going on i decided to show you a
separate discord
and i kind of convinced chevy glad
everyone could come in
and work with us okay and
the rest is history i just kept going
from there
wow i remember no no it'll be like that
i broke people's spirits yeah because
they forgot
it was it that they forgot or one clue
was kind of
wrong there was one twist that made it
so it happened
there was say the last part
there was a clue that wasn't really
specific
and so i had a spreadsheet and i sent a
bunch of people to test things
and someone incorrectly entered
that it was the wrong answer
so we found it multiple days early but
no one realized
that was the answer wow oh man
wow how much time was lost after that
wow good day oh god
that has got to be yeah i remember that
that community was stumped it was a
big this is a lesson be accurate with
your data
seriously hey she appreciates that i
guarantee you
after that day and a half lost
that is true though that is true yeah i
remember that the only
crazy crazy time in the community yeah
so i remember all that craziness going
down and i think you guys took it to
another level for quarters of time
it's like a whole company whereas my
movie was like a few people this was
hundreds that's so crazy it was that
that brought so many people together
i said what what are some of your
favorite like discoveries you know
during the whole race secret stuff like
so what are some of the things that you
really
look back and reflect on and you're like
wow that was a fun time or
you really enjoyed it
good morning david stick out to me hi
naobi
because just the the hours of no
sleep and
it was an absolute mess of a time and i
appreciate it
you thrive you thrive in chaos yeah so
you said no you said three right he said
the second is zero zero um
that was the collaboration with math
class but figuring out
being a uh the different
unlock sequences and
the state was that we kind of figured
ourselves out and it was really quick
and then of course quarters
nice nice those are three good ones
those are three
good ones and the community aspect of of
corridors and
like i said now only with this
difficulty and of course you know
zero hour how much fun that was and and
also the secrets for um
was it the terminals and stuff like that
yeah yeah that that was a lot involved
with that saloons
that's pretty cool that's a great great
uh three great stories from that
gotta respect it what you got here uh
well in the world of destiny
uh i kind of like how between d1 and d2
you're half like me and half-life
cognito
you are leaning cognito's way currently
you are one with the
shade binder we'll get to here in a
little bit yes
so we got a fellow warlock on the
podcast apparently uh
you shall not pass now you guys if you
don't have that emote you have to have
that now because now you have the staff
i do
you shall not pass no it just needs to
be white you just need to put a shader
on your emote
aries we know you're revenant for life
we get it
we'll talk to you later you're fine yeah
let's get it what about you like started
you on the titan
but what made you switch to the warlock
come d2 is there any like
ability change or
i what playing chess and i realized that
blink had a lot of utility and when g2
came around warlock was the only class
that had blank
and since i had started pvp with a bling
clock
and it's like this is actually where we
need to go
[Laughter]
and it's stuck so the pvp decided the
character
yeah makes sense it makes sense yeah
shout out shout out salute to the
warlocks out there you know he knew rad
stand up you know we gotta hop in the
building we have representation today
this is very good we're very happy about
this but no that's a good point that's a
good point because um
you know that void class is always for
pvp
you know that that blinks mm-hmm really
good so shout out to the void locks out
there
blinking around i remember when you were
running a void lock sir and you were
like dude this is so broken
and then they finally nerfed it and it
was like you had your just like knees
like busted underneath yeah it was
brutal
wait what was it that uh nova warp
debuted what was it for
you yeah never worked was this for a
second
and i was just like because i think at
that time let's be real like um
the other classes kind of got more
popularity they look cooler
you had the mall with the titan and you
know
more fun and that no one looks nice but
sadly hasn't ever gotten as much love as
excuses
fire tornado could be better what i
remember i'm like
there's a grenade that kills
people in one shot and there's a super
that i just
poof around the map and kill the whole
squad and catch them again respawning
and killing it i was like
this is broken i was doing 10 streaks
i'm like yeah they this game
especially because it's one of my
favorite things to do
is if an enemy is running tether yeah if
you timed it right
you could zoom out of the tubing and it
would just do nothing
see this is crap i'm a titan and i still
know it's crap but i faced it for a
little while
a little bit uh i mean we we were
running wild for a bit like
once the secret got out and everybody
just started doing it
because boylocks were terrorizing the
crucible
yeah we got hit with that bad hammer
quick we got that nerf excuse
the good old days when things are broken
a little bit broken i'm just sitting
over here on my schmuck titan who had
i got my hammers for a little while in
taking king and then i got
smacked around i've always had bottom
cheese striker though
fair point facts facts talk about it
i don't i agree okay maybe i'm just like
not smart i don't use that one that
often so
i should but i don't yeah i never have
really been that good
i've always been slightly attached to my
if i really want to play pvp
even if it's just like quick play or
anything if i want to actually like not
go after a specific quest which is
usually half the time i'm in there
anyway
uh it's typically going to be hammers
for me i know i always appreciate you
with a sun
titan but my question is this is a
question i never asked you this i'm glad
we talked about this
i never hear you talk fun police
like oh i never hear like you there's no
dark side of the void with e
like i i'm sorry dark side of the void
let me tell you when i face uh avoid
titan i think it's the most
disrespectful thing when i so i have my
super ready and they're like i've
stopped that shut it off
i've done it i've watched like i've
watched people be so
good with that and it's hilarious to
watch i've done it like i've dabbled
like here or there and especially if i'm
running around on my titan
sometimes i'll be like playing code of
the commander for pve which i love it in
there
because the void explosion chains are
just beautiful but
uh if i'm in pvp i might switch over be
like i'm on void i'm like well i miss
will switch grenades so i'll do that and
then i'll play suppressor and it is
it is really really satisfying just to
like kind of bounce it towards you like
i don't care if i get suppressed i'm
going to suppress you and it's going to
be the fun part and it's just like
i don't do it that often though like if
i'm going to play and try and
i don't usually play fun places like my
class and you know
captain america with
apparently i don't i pvp some i don't
pvp as much more mostly pve
so yeah it's like i need to just
experiment with more
stuff more so i get kind of stuck in my
hammer throwing it's just fun to chuck a
hammer a little
little curve on it there's one thing
about just taking a giant scale
yeah big flaming hammer thrown
can't tell you how much fun it is to
nail like a point with two or three
people on it halfway across the map and
get the art trajectory just right
feels good oh yes and i guess maybe it's
it might be more just the fact that it
gives me the range play which is
probably just safer for me
as opposed to getting up in the mix like
the people who like
run charge like dash dash and like they
get in there and screw you over i'm like
man like it's
skillful to watch i just i'm not as good
at it so yeah schmuck over here that's
pretty much all i'm saying i need to
practice that's all this whole
discussion lies dude
last question though that never was the
bubble tightened not had it like
excited you i i always felt like that
was that
now like warlocks i mean if i want to if
it's on control it'd be like
sup and just chill yeah no bubble titan
on control is really fun to use
uh i just rather would rather be more
active than just
hanging out with the bubbles okay i got
you guys your support role is but you
prefer
being an actor which is funny because in
world of warcraft i was always a healer
i was always a healer before and now i
want to go smack stuff around so who
knows
interesting solutes it was a healer a
tank i never played dps maybe that's why
i'm not a warlock
everybody was dps you needed healers and
you needed tanks
i had one of each i had a druid and i
had a warrior so
yep fair enough fair enough someone
that's on how like this as far as now
like
you know you getting into streaming like
the whole content creation aspect and
you know what kind of inspires you there
to say you know what you know i really
want to do this now you know
so the original it's like
when i was like i mean a teen i guess
there would be teens i
started streaming on twitch it didn't
make me go anywhere
and originally used to prove that i
could do it
and over time we ended up cultivating
community and now i kind of
go live every day for them more than me
yeah that's one of those things i've
kind of noticed about watching you on
twitter
and then on the stream and everything is
you do you're pretty selfless you do a
lot of things
you're a nice rock for other people to
hang out with um
to lean on and just a really positive
like beacon for a lot of people to be
around so it's kind of
a lot it's good to have those in the
community especially
when we don't need to dwell on but there
was some stuff that went down and you
were
you were really like important piece of
that it was really nice to watch
like the stronger people in the
community
and all those things and it was just
thank you yeah it's good to have people
like you in the community they are
they're very very important even if like
not everybody may know or see all the
things like the stuff you do like
selflessly like kicking ass in the
background for um
the raid secrets or just like streaming
or just everything that was going down
all the support you gave to everybody
was
it was amazing so yeah it's just wanted
to thank you for that
yeah absolutely absolutely yeah sure for
sure
but you guys think you'd say
that's that's kind of the big thing it
seems it does seem kind of like
do the right thing seems common sense
but it isn't
actually that common anymore which is
really sad
uh but yeah uh as for
what's the what's up with the frogs i
gotta know
how did that start what's the ceo of the
frogs thing people may know
people may not my favorite animal is sea
turtle
not a frog but when people saw my name
they associated with frogs and they
asked for foggy notes
and it became the channel mascot and i
said you know what i'm gonna play into
it
yeah that's that's exciting without that
actually makes perfect sense hey at
least you're in the reptile you're in
the reptile family frog
turtle i mean you're good there but
that's so funny to hoplite so i have the
ceo of all frogs i see that notification
come up and it just kills me every time
yeah hilarious hilarious warning guys
they're doing construction
so yeah so cognito's got construction
and yeah it's like
um joys of construction well while
cognito is silent
he can't say anything about this so
i want to actually say something for
cognito
while he's silent and can't defend
anything so
uh i want to introduce my co-host and
this is a gentleman who has been making
the rounds this week
uh he was the co-host of
unlocked the ign xbox podcast got to
spend some time on there with destin
ryan mccaffrey the dream xbox podcast
absolutely crushed it this week and then
turned around
back-to-back showings yesterday was on
fire team chat
uh this man making their own man how
does it feel to be a star in hollywood
now sir
how is it going how do you feel what are
you gonna do are you gonna go to
disneyland what's next
look man it is it has been a surreal
week uh i will say that
um never in a million years that i think
i would be on
both unlocked and um you know five team
chat and one with let's just say
i want to thank everybody like i don't
get emotional a lot
but this week made me very emotional
just to see everyone show the support
and happy for me to be there and you
know and both
you know these are both dream scenarios
like you're the guy i lean on you know i
cheer you on
you you know as far as your endeavors
like for me one of you my proudest
moments i always tell you this
you know see you on dcp and stuff like
that so for me i'm just like i'm the low
cod
you know i just run my mouth and talk
about gaming and i'm not that big in the
community but
to see people you know galvanize and and
come
for supporting me yo truly humbling i
want to thank everybody that showed up i
see the comments
and like i said it would i shed a little
tear i was
like wow like this this really feels
good but yeah salute to podcast unlocked
we had a great show and then obviously
salute to desolate gary
the entire you know fire team chat we
talked about obviously a live reaction
of the stasis stuff and
you know i had to shout out that last
word
and shout out to desolate gary to watch
your name because your new name
is ebonidas oh hell no that's not
sticking
and if you guys stick i'm gonna boot you
out of my chat so don't do it
all this time no one corrected me i've
been saying his name wrong
i'm like yeah i was like bro i said
ebonitis oh ryan mccabe said i mean that
sounds like a disease
i was like well evan i didn't sound like
a biblical character yeah that's what i
thought
so salute to salute to destin oh man it
was it was what's up man
hey thank you man it was it was truly a
phenomenal weekend
a lot of fun man so someone definitely
had to shout you out i mean like this
if you guys haven't ever watched iron
lord's podcast you are missing out on
a lot of like great discussion between
some awesome guys a lot of passion for
i mean can't say like a lot of passion
for the xbox beauty but just like gaming
in general
life-changing for those guys especially
just like as a community coming together
for some people it's like they fall in
games as opposed to falling into
many other things that aren't as good
growing up so it's like gaming bringing
these guys together
talking about it and then now it's just
this bond that they have they talk and
give each other crap
the guests that they get on there are
really fantastic overall
like if you guys don't watch ireland
podcast go over there and then this man
out here trying to like burn the candle
at both ends between work
having like a gaming website that he got
off the ground and everything
and then now seeing you get this week
man it's
like years and decades of hard work and
it's paying off i'm glad to see it man
thank you brother man like i said you've
always been an inspiration
in that regard so to see your journey
and then like i said
you know just just getting i guess
recognition you know recognition always
feels good you always feel good and
i feel for us it's just like you know
the good guys you know getting getting a
little shine
you know sometimes we feel the
negativity wins sometimes but it's good
for the good guys to actually get some
support and stuff like that
it's dope man it's cool and shout out to
everybody to chat every everybody
one cool comment too i saw in the
comments was like wait a minute i know
him he's on the last word
oh all right you know me from somewhere
you know me all right
i like that i like that so sorry hop not
trying to take away from you at the
guest but at a shout out
shout out my co-host so no that was just
a big one
and thank you for the support you always
absolutely we've been
we've been through a fair amount of
thick and thin on this crazy game so
nice to nice to see it
um but yeah hop um as
for you thank you for bringing all the
frogs and greatness with you today so
a bad case if you bounce what
it's deep it's it's getting into the
lungs man i gotta go see the dock it's
uh it's
it's gone from the nose to the throat
it's getting bad whatever that is
now yo they going in
thank you for this by the way it was
good dude
you couldn't have scripted i said when i
was on podcast a lot i said e
whatever you do watch the final five
minutes
it was pure comedy watching this man
butcher your name
and i thoroughly enjoyed it and i said
i'll go use it
like in in fairness like unfairness to
him it's like
i'm popped into his chat and stuff i've
always i've followed those guys forever
i've followed ign for as long as i can
remember
so i was like popped into his chat when
he'd be streaming and stuff be like hey
and
i don't he he'd seen the name because
like whether it's a question popped and
answered it whatever it was
it's hard to tell somebody how to
pronounce your name by text i mean i
could write it out as like a big capital
e
space b o n space tis like i could
but i'm not really i'm not that type of
person to do that in like somebody's
chat i'm just like hey if you say it
whatever
my last name has been messed up for most
of my life so i'm kind of used to it
anyway so
it wasn't that far off at least the
letters were right as opposed to what my
last name's been through so it's fine
but now he made sure he made it right
though he was when i was five to chat
you you definitely
nailed it yeah so yeah yeah you're black
wings you do it too much you do it too
i once caught an ebonitis to the knee
black is that what that is the last word
yo because it sounds very romantic
host of the last wordiest yes very very
roman very spartacus
let me just go get my like helmet and
your titan every night is detained y'all
oh man well nothing else happened so
great episode guys awesome to meet you
hoplite thank you
no i'm just kidding uh so yeah yesterday
we waited about an hour and 45 minutes
to get our
stasis trailer um
now i know that's marketing i'm going to
be honest completely but
they're like yeah we got and it's just
like jeff keeley's just like dragging us
on and dragging
be like get through the entire gamescom
trailer then
fall guys destiny 2 ratchet and click
bam bam bam done
like they even kicked it off with like
call of duty was like okay they might
make some stuff
no maybe they can't pace it up no like
bookends
on a pod on a show and then there was
some interesting stuff in the middle i'm
not gonna
lie but i was like i'm waiting for one
thing and i was like
you're killing me here dude you think
they placed the major wheel stuff and so
you kind of backloaded it
oh there was one i was even watching
this some of you guys were in here
yesterday when i was watching it
whatever they were watching it was like
a more serious game
and then instantly flipped to that like
cartoony wrestling game like this all
the tr
i'm like you have random transitions of
like youtubers talking here about this
that's where you put one of those right
there i was like the
i'm not gonna be the conference guy i'm
not like a producer but at that moment i
wanted to be one because i was like that
didn't fit
you know what else did you fit when they
bring godfall on the screen it looks
better
for 12 seconds and it was like five
times
yeah they like i was just ready to smell
the food and they just yanked it away
and i'm like
be like
they were laughing at me on the street
because i was pumping it up they didn't
clown me on my stream oh yeah they all
better
though you should have hear the laugh
because i was i was pumped i'm like i
really want to get excited about this
game
and then it was like what the heck yeah
that was like
somebody i don't know somebody sent them
the wrong i don't know what it was but
it was
it's like almost like an emergency like
oh we need a clip like uh here's 12
seconds of this guy
yeah because i mean i've seen er i've
seen uh eric's he had like kind of an
exclusive but that was like
13 minutes of gameplay showing some
classes and like
where's like even a minute it was just
so weird but yeah godfather's still
excited about ratchet and clank looks
fantastic if you guys go watch that 4k
trailer just
even when clank you haven't seen it uh
oh
yeah go watch that one but like when he
the one clank i think i
haven't actually played the two i heard
the one on ps4 is actually pretty good
though
um but when he's talking just like
starting to see what ray tracing the
reflections on the floor from everything
above just getting a feel for
seeing the right tracing in action just
because it's starting to get more and
more predominant with like the new
graphics cards come in the like the
nvidia 3000 series and rdna 2 all that
stuff's coming and then the consoles
like
ray tracing start gonna start to be a
thing and it's it's a subtle thing
but makes everything just feel that much
more real which oh yeah i feel it's
gonna have a similar effect
to uh what my console guys finally
experienced on
hdr hdr was a game changer too you know
saying if you haven't really seen a high
dynamic range
really good so you got that and ray
tracing these are going to be
a lot of things people are going to get
excited about and uh yeah yeah
ratcheting clank definitely they did the
thing man it was really important to me
one of the most
i know we're going off something for a
second but launch window
yeah lunch window that was that was big
that was big which adds another feather
to the cap
yeah for sony the launch and unlike
another console the lost and exclusive
you know
these are things that people gravitate
towards consoles so actually if i can
if i can get like the rumored demon
souls
as well oh no my trifecta my trifecta um
i will have today if that's a day one
yeah
alex said the same thing he's expert
he's like look he's probably gonna buy
one
he said if demon souls is there oh he's
gonna have issue he's gonna have to take
him
see you guys i gotta go talk to a blue
it's the same thing from the only thing
with me is i guess for me the only way
it would happen is like
let's say for example goes to shima
didn't exist right on playstation four
and they announced it as a new game and
played five oh [ __ ] oh yeah
what about you hop where are you at on
this whole console thing because
besides the giant game of price chicken
which is still killing me
were you do you typically play consoles
pc i mean i know you got a pc fairly
recently for streaming
um i used to play an xbox or my xbox
finally
broke like two weeks ago oh damn
that recent yeah
was it like the eight-year-old like day
one or which xbox
which i spot i don't know i think i'm
gonna actually pass on this
consolidation at least for a bit
okay stick with pc until
i have a reason to go back to console
but i just wanted to ask you
which version of the xbox broke was it
the xbox one s the xbox one x the old
xbox with the
original one i got in 2013 oh you had
the vcr
yeah i've got the day one controller
mine's still going but
mine just plays like netflix and movies
so that's all yeah
when i see you mine's a media console
yeah i already know it's movie night
with the wife i was like is there's
nothing even going on every streaming
service and a blu-ray player those are
my pinned buttons there's not a game on
that console
clearly clearly i see you i'm like i'm
not even gonna send him a message
yeah i mean you're not wrong that's
but yeah for the new consoles i mean
that's kind of the thing too is like i
want a
ps5 is the one i'm leaning towards
because like xbox is going to get me to
play
whatever they're like the medium and
score is it yes
it's not scorn because i keep wanting to
say is it scoring score
is the they're freaky looking yeah and
then the medium with like the two
realities looks awesome
and that's the one that got me like
those granted if they're on game pass
i'm gonna play my piece my pc so what
i'm sitting here staring at is like
how much is this 33 the 30 90
no am i doing that right yeah the gtx
3900
um yeah the brand new ones like 24 gig
of memory and i'm like i'm just waiting
for it to break my wallet so september
1st
next week tuesday we get to see what all
that stuff's all about so
uh we get to see how broke i get to be
uh when those things launch
i'm going to be living vicariously
through you sir seeing how you
see here's the problem with that i've
got a 1080 ti
i can't argue it's actually been putting
up pretty well i don't have a high
refresh rate monitor
oh you got it yeah so i have to do
both oh yeah you're in trouble yeah yeah
yeah so it's like big gpu yeah looking
at about 1500 bucks if i
if that's what the 3090 is like and then
to make sure and use the 30 90 i'm like
and this is my issues like if i do a
console and they do whether it's 4k
checkerboard or 4k or whatever it is
they do 4k
so i want to enjoy that on console so
i'm sitting here looking at a 4k
144 hertz monitor i'm like gonna cry
yeah bro you're gonna lose it i'm gonna
go broke
yeah for me it was like the best thing
again i know that the whole meme with
the xbox one game thing but
the best thing for me was like i said
the the the beyond light
game pass because now i'm gonna go there
and then i'm gonna do my my um c10 q leg
joint
i mean oled joint and then um get that
at 120 that uh
hdmi 2.1 and that dss and the vr
variable voice changed we lost them the
voice changes i'm sorry i didn't
understand you
you know all that hotness you know
got to take it to the level these new
systems you got to maximize y'all so
yeah that's what i'll be doing you're
going to see non-cat
yeah i was thinking about the c9 just
hard to find no i'm not doing tcl neil
mentioned
no i'm that so are you so i wanted to
ask you um
hop for your background i know with like
raid secrets and stuff but
i was like are you like what are you are
you computer science
am i wrong uh cpr in marketing
oh why don't you can't back up but the
ultimate goal is game devs
okay so i thought there was like some
piece in there
pr and marketing so like start with
community manager get your foot in the
door
type thing or more marketing for me is
probably move towards
qa and then eventually target production
nice have you had any experience yet or
talk to any i know
uh there's some companies in the texas
area so there's a few sprinkled
throughout i don't know if there's any
ones you're looking at
experience with indie stuff but i'm
looking to
every podcast gotta have one okay as
long as we stay up and that's all
that's all i'm concerned about i could
be like solid for three hours but one
time in there it's gotta go
well uh apparently we made it this far
in very distracted by many things well
we got to talk about stasis
sorry for the delay everybody i
apologize but we had to get talked to
our
obviously our guest the wonderful and
awesome hoplite and then i had to
see if i could make lord cognito get
emotional again
i mean that give me that one tear just
tattoo it right there wait no that's not
that one
for i told y'all i was very emotional
this week and love the love was was show
for real
um but stasis dropped so
i don't know how you guys want to talk
about just class by class
or how you guys want to break it down i
mean if we go chronological of the way
we're getting the
information so they updated the website
and they have dates so the warlock
september 1st
titan september 3rd hunter september 8th
i guess we can start with a warlock
because
i'm outnumbered so yeah you shade
bunt shade binder i think is the right
one trade binder um
what do you guys think what you thinking
how you feeling about it
it looks so good the only issue is
it's the only superheroes we don't have
gameplay of
all the other ones you can see this one
looks
fascinating it's just you only have like
the brief snippets
right right right they i found yeah they
probably show more the others
i'm not quite sure how it's gonna work
whether it's gonna be an
aoe freeze and then a melee shatter like
how the actual mechanics of the class
are gonna function it looks great
i'm super into like the mage staff but
we gotta see that gameplay
i
as a warlock i think there's nothing
cooler
than having like this lord of the rings
slash merlin staff
aesthetically it fits a warlock so in
that part of me
super excited um you make it a good
point hop in the sense that um
you know as far as the mechanic because
it seems like it's two part now
i'll shout out to you that's those guys
kind of trying to figure it out too and
i want to bring this to you
you know we're seeing almost like this
freeze
and then a shatter mechanic yes well the
question i want to bring to both of you
is during the free state because we're
seeing it in pvp
also right the wall i put it down golden
gun came down it was like freeze you
stop stop that right so we saw that
motion that was cool
but the question is do we think the free
status means you're already dead
or you're just slowed and then the
shadow is what kills you
so like what do you guys think about
that those two mechanics
you're first so yeah okay so so i think
that the
the phrase is a weird mechanic which
as someone who comes from competitive
overwatch scares me a little
was the cc meta especially as like a
main tank player
so that means i was constantly gonna hit
the cc and play
controls being taken away it scares me a
little
but again we just don't know enough yeah
yeah i know
how it's gonna work good point good
point e
what are you thinking sir uh so you were
so you were saying
saying you think it's like crowd control
something like that but do you think
they can't get out of it
sorry i didn't quite catch um yeah yeah
so like i'm i'm with i'm with that camp
like i think you can be frozen
but if you're not shot killed slid
through shattered in any way i think you
can
unfreeze okay so my opinion is that it
is a
crowd control mechanic but if you die
after kill after like freezing them
you're eventually gonna get out it's
gonna work like a debuff it may suck
while you're debuffed you may just get
to watch this dude walk over and thump
you and shatter you
but yeah i still think you can get out
of it if you are not
affected while frozen that's my that's
my guess
yeah that's gonna be the question then i
guess also duration how long does it
last
like like almost like a suppressed
ability you know
you look like you're frozen in place
look like you're not easy target
so it's going to be interesting there's
so many
you know nuances to it and i think for
me
i just want like i said that's how i
feel about like
i am impressed with how much
they are changing the sandbox
okay this is i'll be honest
when you hear about a subclass you hear
about these kind of things
you know you figure cool abilities but
we're getting abilities that are
literally changing and metamorphosizing
the sandbox and all these
cool way it's exciting because they're
really going
balls of the wall and doing all types of
crazy cool ideas but then there's
another part of me that's like
wow like crucible is gonna be crazy
like there's a part of me that's scared
but happily scared because it's you want
them to go crazy you want them to go
through here's my tape
can i get squeezed last more than one to
two seconds
we're going to have a problem
iniqvisible
if it is a one to two second freeze the
ttk on mustangs is about point seven
five seconds to one second
so it's reasonable you get too much
longer past that
mm-hmm
yeah these are valid valid little
concerns you know we got to see how it
plays out you know
because i will say not to cut you out
but like
in pve this looks amazing right
do this boom if you're on the recipient
of these freezing
i don't know how i'm gonna be cheering
that on as much
hey i was just gonna say like out sanity
asked the question
and he said uh i wanted to ask all of us
will stasis be too op
or screw up pvp and i just wanna be like
yes it's gonna be 2op yes it's going to
screw up pvp and i'm totally for it
oh you're [ __ ] yeah i'm totally for
sandbox insanity
i'm sure oh well you know what you're
right it does make sense you being a
mayhem
lover and yeah okay oh i get it i didn't
even picture that mayhem yet
bring him it's gonna be nuts
oh that's gonna be beautiful freezing
so from what i can gather from my crazy
frame by frame analysis i've said
trailer since i'm oh you broke it down
i'm already broken down like all five
ways to sunday let's go let's go
there's a video coming but i was trying
to get it before the podcast but i had
to sleep instead
so i had to be awake for this thing so
it looks like the warlock obviously has
the staff but you have two ways it looks
like you shoot
roughly three to four little projectiles
out
yeah you shoot the projectiles and then
they like kind of have
it's either like a burst explosion to
like freeze everything but it
doesn't look like that's like an instant
kill depending on how it hits
but then like if they kind of like walk
up in between all the frozen guys
and then just do like the from the staff
the radiated like pulse of energy
just shatters everything i'm just oh
it's gonna be so
like the lockdown and then just like and
if the nuke
i say nuke but you know the explosion
shatters or if not already frozen
then it freezes the other people i'm
just like the
these are really because you're gonna
need dps you're still gonna need your
golden guns you're still gonna need your
hammers however you do it
but the control that this is gonna bring
to a raid for like
hey we got enemies coming out this door
i'm like well not anymore they're all
frozen
like the uncontrolled that you're gonna
have
i can only picture esoteric just like
solo flawlessing everything because
nothing can move he's just gonna have
the entire
the entire encounter is gonna be frozen
he's just gonna be sitting over there
like
flip it flipping uh something around so
it looks like you've got the projectiles
and then also the burst with your soap
so you guys have both range
you can like shoot and still nova warp
that's like a kind of a lethal
combination because normally like nova
warp you gotta
you gotta go there and now you can shoot
something that's kind of terrifying
yeah it's it's pretty powerful i mean
hop what do you what are you thinking
like are you excited about like these
you know so many options within the
super it seems right it seems like this
without a doubt the the fact that it can
be used in a variety of ways and adds a
whole new mechanic into the game
this is easily the most in-depth
subclass that you've received thus far
yes in terms of how it can be utilized
yes and it also reminds me one thing i
always jealous of titans i know
he doesn't embrace the void but i always
felt the versatility
of the bubble slash um captain america
slash you know like they had so much to
do with that one soup and i just thought
that's so cool but he doesn't use it but
it's i let my brother play that class
all right
that is like the ultimate protector
i don't know how you don't embrace your
inner captain america man
i totally have it's just like if i'm
playing with my brother that's his
anyway so i'm usually gonna run
something different as it is unless
we're just like
soloing through he's always like tank he
wants to be a titan tank he wants like
rpg stats so he's actually a tank
so he is your bubble forever so if we're
gonna have
alternate from that i'm not going to
play that so let's just play with your
bro
yeah i got to do something okay now i
understand i've played with
a lot of them but i was like if
especially i'm playing with him
yeah i'm definitely going to be
something else yeah he's he's dibs on
tanks yeah he's right right here
thank you for all the crap though i
totally appreciate it
now i will say the other side of the
warlocks though you're freezing rift
we gotta talk about it this looks kind
of
broken if it works now this for one is
like
twofold because potentially it's
changing a class ability which they
haven't done ever
i mean you have the two options but
those have been the two options for a
while so if you have a rift that freezes
do you think it's coming from an exotic
or do you think it's coming
from like the actual skill tree
these like random custom skill trees you
think so
to me it looks like it's coming from the
skill tree because hey
it's pretty situational especially
because i
don't it doesn't look like freezing pve
and pvpa equivalent i don't think you
could refrence and free someone in pvp
but you can in ppe that that probably
sounds accurate
because i'm gonna tell you right um
it takes multiple ticks to feeds in the
pvp game
they showed in tv it's very quick
ah that might be the balance right there
that you've got to get caught into it
for a couple of seconds
almost take the shield off like almost
get down to your critical health
yeah okay and that's when you get it
because not to cut you guys you
you might be thinking it wasn't clear
where the hunter i forgot it's a
crucible map it's a classic crucible map
the hunter throws some type yes throws
that that grenade
and then i guess they're frozen and then
after that throws a shuriken that
bounces off the wall and crashed into
them already
we're getting the hunters but yeah i'm
sorry
just excited it's interesting that maybe
it's like you said for the balance of
pvp instead of it being an
instant freeze and maybe it's okay they
have to be in that for a while
and then you kind of get into the status
that would be bad that would be
interesting
so like if you can like play or like you
know some people come into your rift and
try and punch you and you're sitting
there
if they try and punch you and it's the
wrong or if they're like uh
crap like that yeah i think you could
take them like
the face from reflectivation the other
thing
so the 100 gameplay that i posted the
the comments the mainly overrated for
hunters
it only tracks two frozen targets
if a target isn't a frozen it doesn't
make a change
i was wondering about that because they
had the little in the b-roll they had
the little shanks coming up the stairs
and it hit and i couldn't tell if it
tracked or just like went through three
of them it did look like it hit multiple
times um
but yeah for the it was bounce bounce
between the two walls so those two
bounces don't even count
then it still hit the first target and
then still killed the second one i'm
like how many times does this thing get
to bounce around this is
not fair from my understanding it wicked
shades between all
frozen targets and it has one master
ricochet
damn yeah okay
i'm getting it i'm i'm stopped you
interested you see what uh pablito
savage said imagine if freeze is like a
mechanic where it's applied on a scale
maybe running over riff scales that up
eventually leading to being frozen
so uh what would that almost be like the
what is the dark entropy what's the
recent one in prophecy where you get
like the
you get like a multiplier and the more
that multiplier gets up say it's like
like chill chill chill level like one
two three and then like frozen it like
kind of
escalates the debuff on you maybe i said
to these best
you know that he said i told you listen
i will admit this
as the gaming ninja i see shurikens that
hunter class might have to get made for
this one man
yeah like it's feeling it's feeling very
ninja-esque and you know how i feel
about that
so i might i might have to you know
create that secondary
normally i stick to my one wall i will
but i go for hunters looking nice with
that i
i do like that and they got hey they're
ninjas in a way the hoods they nimble
you know respect to the hunters always
got respect for them
yeah savage is out there saying you
could almost use a rift as a trap
potentially
like have somebody come around the
corner a shotgun and be like oh come
around the corner
and they're just like or at least slowed
recovery bills
oh god oh i got some high recovery
rolled all but just waiting at 1360.
i was actually thinking like i know it
doesn't the two classes don't go
together but the exotic where you like
get the kills and it makes rifts where
you get the kills
i know it's like it's solar so it's not
going to transfer over but in my head
for a second i was like ah
i know it won't but i was like if you
can start using those frozen wrists in
like multiple places
there's the the um what's the one that
is people are close
yup talk about it
preach preach and they also re redid
people forgetting right hop um
sin green alchemy and alchemy yes that
got reworked so that when you
kill with the rifts you keep the rifts
long
that's going to be interesting warlock's
going to be a little scary we got to see
the full properties
if that is regular or if that is an
exotic based property
because it could get scary for y'all if
they let us run loose
it's already going to be scary across
the board but
exciting oh man shotgunners say i may
have a bad time if everybody starts
getting frozen like oh yeah come here
come on in ape come through yeah pull up
now one thing uh new red did um i wanted
to ask you guys because they mentioned
this yesterday i didn't even get to it
in my video
but um if you notice on some of the
gameplay it says orbs of
power not orbs of light yes
and since we have now darkness is it
just like their generic term of orb
now is just like an orb of power versus
an orb that was like a very subtle
distinction somebody kind of like oh
damn
so what do you guys is that think like
the start of the
embracing the darkness i think so
i think it's gonna stick like that going
forward or if it's power
yeah i i think so too i think it's it's
it's verbage
to to associate with the accepting of
this darkness
you know embracing it yeah so uh i'm
with that i want that
yeah i'm gonna get my crackpot for you
for the next few years
absolutely we love these things go down
that lower rabbit hole we are here for
it
i'm thinking rich queen you get a second
darkness of cross
light fall we get a third darkness and
then we have to choose
because in the trailer it says this side
must be chosen
whether it's the wrong one or not so i'm
thinking some might follow
we make that please tell me we have a
horde and alliance world of warcraft
please
oh you're you're preaching to the choir
over here hop
come oh that sounds so exciting because
if you had
and and can you picture pvp now light
versus dark
come on oh my god what
oh salute salute hold on sorry gotta
pause and chat
vagabondo dropping the sub outsanity
kicking up a notch i'm savage in here
just dropping all the love thank you
guys very much for the support today you
guys are all
fantastic um just damn to all of you so
thank you sorry i had to shout that out
my apologies
absolutely the love is tremendous
probably dope
everybody that's what's up man oh so
yeah cognito what do you think
do you like the idea of having to
pick like only being only having one
side available like at some point you
can't have like 12 sub classes yeah you
have 12.
but i was like do you would you have an
issue
picking one side or the other like
i'm a yeah i'm a dark guy versus a like
you know do you
how do you think that would go i think
it's a cool idea i think it's i mean
again when we went to
we heard about the initial leaks what is
it our good our good friend another nine
yes these things they were talking about
right uh
light versus and i think hop hop you
nailed it because
you know if you if they introduce
a darkness subclass you know each
september whatever
that we're going to get to that point of
like you said which it's just so many
abilities right
so you're just not going to be able to
have all of these things you're not
at once so i think that yeah at that
point then it becomes
two separate factions light dark
you know these were part of the rumors
you know guardians have to choose
and yeah like they're already setting up
the verbiage as far as you know
power orbs of power versus orbs of light
you know we're already i don't know if
you guys have been really following
the um the cradle speeches from eris
but uh you know every week you know
she's saying so something more about the
communication with the darkness
something to the fact that you know
we're being held back
and you know there's other things so
this this could get really deep lore
wise and
it would be cool it would be cool i
think this
i would have no problem with that i i
would literally have no problem with
that
and and to see that and if they if they
really do what the anonymous said i
don't know if you guys remember that
rumor which the whole
pvp versus e patrol zones
light and dark kind of thing now we're
talking
now we're talking so it'll be it'll be
fun what you think i've like
i think that they may create story
distinctions but for the purposes of
balance
i think regardless of which side you
choose you can still wield the light of
the dark they think it would be a choice
between pyramids and travelers
but you can use both sides
okay i'll show you actually because
otherwise
like if the light subclasses are strong
and you can't access them and create the
problem
i guess it just kind of depends that
also depends on balance i guess too to
see how much they can get
that's like three years away we are so
far within that right now
but yeah it is exciting to think of the
future of the game that's kind of one of
those things some people were like oh is
the game going to end after lightfall is
that the end or is that the beginning
and that's kind of what that question is
like does this build up to like
an actual d3 at that point or what comes
next so
yeah now that's really exciting stuff
yeah you warlocks are going to kill us
all
listen man titan's still running today
man you guys flying through the sky
doing all the time we can do we get to
y'all savages yet do we do we
are we up to you wow i'm a savage damn
dude
i'm not the one using like throwing
hatchets and stuff like that come on
hulk thing that we wait till we get to
y'all we can do it right now
let's get some we got behemoth that's us
i guess we're embracing the big boy
standard
it's like what are you are you small and
dainty no i'm a behemoth i'm ginormous
apparently it says crash like an
avalanche is the text on it
so from what we can tell we got two
things for the titan i'm gonna embrace
this one because this is my class
one now this is where i wonder you guys
have like a staff that seems to kind of
do both and i'm wondering
how much i guess they can do with some
stuff i wanna know how different this
subclass feels to
arc because in theory it looks to
function very similar
because you have a slam and then you
have the rome
it might be like a punch instead of like
a shoulder charge
but you have i love the effect it looks
like he punched his hand into ice
and then just pulled out whatever sucked
to his hand and it's just this like
giant white ice fist that looks really
cool that's a really bad
graphic if somebody clips that out of
context right
[Laughter]
sponsorship sorry dirty mind totally
happens
but it's got this like awesome white ice
fist but the thing that starts at all
whether it's like whether you cast it or
if you're running around and you can
still do the roaming slam
is this like kind of cone of
the ice little pillars this little
earthquake that comes out of the ground
and it's just like uh and it seems to
either freeze damage both kind of
similar to the way the warlocks is like
the freeze first
maybe like a second shot might shatter
it sends out that like wave of energy in
front of you it seems a really cool cool
way like if you got
somebody in the general direction ahead
of you just take them completely out
and then after that you still seem to
actually run around punch freeze punch i
don't know what do you guys think about
this one
is it cool is it not a school what do
you guys think about this
what do you think so i think that it's
definitely gonna have its own utility it
seems
almost like a hybrid between burning
mall and fists of havoc
as far as i can tell the overhead slam
is going to be a heavy attack
and the light attacks the melees it's
the same thing with this sandbox
designer said
the punch with the big ice fist
that is your melee that isn't mainly
override outside of super
wow so you pull in the ice around your
hands and you hit
really hard wow
over here so that has me
excited yeah i heard that's what i heard
somewhere is that like the melees
cooler than anything they've done for
the titan is that kind of
yeah so i was like i want to know what
that's all about
bless you
um what about you cognito did it look as
menacing as a freezing rift crazy
warlock or are you just like
it's another it's another titan runner
around trying to punch me
i don't like that i don't like that wall
i don't like the grenade
or that the the wall that you're
constructing
hey the hunter does it too bro that you
guys are creating fortnite it's like a
skyscraper you might be able to do the
same thing we don't know if the grenades
are universal yet i'm wondering if they
are
what y'all did and that control point
and this man constructs a whole wall and
then
you know the titan jump can easily scale
that and then come crashing down in the
eyes like like the control that they're
gonna have
to control different spaces and lock
things down that
people don't realize barrier is one of
the coolest abilities
right if used correctly this thing you
can't
see through it now that's crazy it's
going to be
and you know we'll get to the hunters
what they could do which is scaring me
as well
but that part i go for a little
a little shook i was like i don't know
if i like them with that
look up there damn titans man that
that's scary man like
that's like yo imagine you sniping
someone and you'll be like you'll stop
you just literally construct a whole
sheetrock like we put this sheetrock up
over here
and
room separation apparatus little drywall
like what is this
so what do you think cop about that
grenade that what do you think the
apparently ice wall i don't know what
it's going to be called but what do you
think about that grenade
so from pve perspective
awesome it looks like it's going to
block that futuristic map that's great
because someone who plays pvp
competitively
mm-hmm that's gonna be an instagram
there's
no way like that is so like
how can you stop that like exactly
basically you can block off huge poisons
the map
so me and you were talking and we were
like there's no way that's
used in scrims oh come on
they gotta try to mix it up on
landscapes
in child's
just like sweaty scrubs though you're
out
i don't know how they gonna be able to
control this like i mean it's fun it's
exciting i don't
imagine like six titans just like
you have the great you have the great
wall of ice
like they're gonna change before it may
build a goddamn [ __ ] but it's a
fortnight now
like literally you can build structures
with titans
hunter throws the thing in the first
trailer we saw like
a couple months ago hunter is the one
who throws it in the middle of the map
and then hops over it oh no we will get
to them but we will get it
they do it too so i was like trust me
but i'm just like
man of course look we overreacted we
don't know it doesn't
i will say it doesn't seem to have that
much health like when they throw it in
front of the enemies it seems to already
lose one brick
he hits it with one arrow and nothing
bust it goes so it doesn't look like
it's gonna have a lot of health
it may be that like in a pinch throw it
run by as it's kind of like
dying behind you type thing but it may
it may not have as much
it's ice it may take one bullet to
shatter it may not take that long but
the visual
break of at least throw it you don't
know where they are you can still like
oh i need to get by this doorway but
somebody's got me hardscoped well now i
can
like that's the potential to at least
flank change mobility move positions
that type of stuff is where i think it's
got
at least potential to get out of a
crappy situation oh actually yeah if
it's casual then we're good
yeah well it's it'll just take it out
then
yeah like if one pulse burst and it does
go in chunks because like when they have
the
the one in front of the enemies you have
like four or five chunks
it's like one chunk fell and there's
three on the left and one the right so
it can break in pieces which is also
really cool
um you know what i can't wait to do
these though
so i can't wait and because it's
supposed to feel like i need that
fly or jump on top of it and just hang
over doorways on a platform
oh my god
i can picture the the map that they use
in the trailer just have that above
point b
somebody walks in hey and you're like
sup bam
this could get crazy oh man this is this
and then what about it think about this
titans
your exotic synergy with this stuff
okay hit me hit me an example what do
you think
what about doesn't that one all right
first of all let's classify are we
are they classifying this wall thing as
a grenade or a clasp
it's definitely a grenade it's thrown
and now it appears it's definitely
switch switch switch cause it's not that
it's not the titan barricade that's
right because i was like if they had
that type and but the other one though
armentarium bro
like that's going to be it's going to
yep crystal knows you have
armamentarium is going to be scary scary
you giving these guys grenades running
around being able to do a fortnight
business and construct
structures it's gonna be it's gonna be
something man
and a whole bunch of titans getting
together it's camp central
it's cold you had like a bunch of titans
with armamentarium
you could literally like slowly like
wall a team in
if anybody jumps up they're just like
it's like duckling just target practice
so you like lock everybody in a point
and they're like stuck in there and then
they try and jump up and everybody's
like
i'm just picturing control like who's
going to stop them from capping b
oh if you got four titans oh you only
you only need two titans with rm and
terror and just wall wall wall
b is captured
it's got a lot of potential i reserve a
judgment until it go i gotta tease you
because you always give me crab about
warlock's got that this is scary stuff
yeah well if you have it too you have no
argument if these grenades are universal
uh you don't know if you do i've only
seen your class
you've seen the hunter use it too though
he uses it as a platforming
jumping ability thing no the hunter uses
it
in the same exact fashion you can build
a wall like this
same exact way it was the trailer two
months ago
and it's when they're in the middle of
it's used to be widows court if i don't
know it's the same it's not called the
same thing
it's in the middle of that open space
like the big open courtyard
he's running through it throws it down
and then jumps over it do you not
remember this from like two months ago
i don't remember it being i think what
it is is i don't remember
the height of it oh it's huge because
he's got to like
double together and it was a hunter yes
100
dude where do you get a chance later
show me offline yeah i just don't
remember a hunter
yeah i'm not saying a lot no that's well
that's the other piece too is like
that's why i keep wondering if the
grenades are universal like
no because you got multiple classes and
they kind of describe a couple
so titan punchy of course
we got the cone of shockwave earthquake
avalanche flying forward
and then of course crazy wall now the
hunter
yes in case we weren't terrified enough
about each other
all of these revenants have to come in
here aries is out here just grinning
like an idiot i know you are
you're out there somewhere i see you um
who wants to take this one because we
got the super called silence and squall
and i haven't heard a better fitting
name after you watch what it does
uh hop you know what i'm talking about
you want to talk about their super
the stupid self looks good without being
broken
per se it's a it's essentially
like a blade brush that phases instead
of just doing damage
mm-hmm and then the afternoon
usually for cc i think it's not going to
be that much more effective than typhoid
except when you factor in the other
abilities
like the third melee that ricochets off
everything
yes then it's gonna start
yeah if you can freeze and then get a
couple i mean what's the double melee
or like double throwing star or
something like that but the other piece
is like this like ice tornado
you guys notice that yes yes that
remains
yeah yeah and it seems to like move
yeah it like tracks either towards
enemies because i know there's the one
you see like the couple of x in them
in the i can't think of this
minotaur it like slowly drifts over to
him it just like
wipes him out mm-hmm
yeah so yeah that one looks crazy and
then there's the other one it's like in
his periphery when it starts
the other two times during the b-roll
gameplay um
he like throws the two axes they hit and
then it kind of starts over here and the
second one
when he's doing what looks to be like
deep stone crypt or more of that like
kind of fallen area
the one with the the can't even think of
the shanks coming up the stairs
if you watch it looks over there and
before the ice wall appears you can see
it like coming towards the enemies like
down the stairs
so if that thing can actually freeze and
then track to take out enemies
that seems kind of also a little
terrifying too
yes stay there it seems to be the theme
with
uh stasis uh scary to fight against
great to use yeah great to use
terrifying to face
this looks like it's going to be
situational so
it's going to be great in pvp and pvp
you might use it a few times down there
i hate you hunters are strong in pvp so
if they get some more support or pve
help probably okay with that they have
enough things to kill me in pvp so it's
totally fine
uh but yeah the the melee the thing that
bounces the three-sided shuriken
um
that one seems sorry did you does it
actually have a name am i calling it the
wrong thing
oh yeah it's a surface it's a comma
comma
okay yeah k-a-m-a gotcha
so the comma the ice or see that's the
thing i keep saying ice
i can't tell you how many times i'm
gonna get ice and stasis and frozen
all interchangeably broken um
but the frozen amma
two bounces and still two enemies and
i'm just like i wanna know
in a very close quarters pvp map how bad
that's gonna be
now if you say it tracks the frozen
enemies that will help some
but if it tracks just to enemies just
bounce that off a corner and you can
have a lot of fun like
i could picture some because they do
their cosmic ice i saw that last night
on dcp
cosmic ice frozen whatever
just do you guys think the melee seems
like pretty cool do you think it'll be
if it's like tracking just a frozen
versus if it tracks everything
i'm kind of curious how much that
thing's actually got potential for
yeah um i don't know if it feels
again i'm just guessing you know
synergistic with
with or you know the frozen stuff i
think it would be
extremely powerful if it did outside of
that but um
you know i'm excited for that that that
that uh hunter shuriken that that
tracking thing
and again that if it feels like a
two-phase mechanic you know
freeze chatter free shatter that kind of
thing so um
it's cool man this i think hop said it
best
like i think in pve now that we get more
information
this thing's gonna be powerful there's
no need these all of these abilities are
gonna be super powerful
i do think in pvp it's going to i think
it may not be as
strong maybe we oh we're seeing the
visual we may be overreacting
and it may not be as crazy as we think
right
you know i'm leaning towards hop now
she's she's calming me down like a
little relax cause that could you see
that it's just so jarring to see
a golden gun hunter stopped in its
tracks like like just
very disrespectfully it's like wow like
i've never seen this type of stuff
before and then you know you see them
you know
you know at the point b on that uh that
classic crucible map
and then titan unfreeze the area and
then here comes the warlock
shattering everyone and i'm just like
very very scary very intimidating
prospects here
remember in one of our favorite examples
of this is the
spray trailer where someone took the
last side and four capped
on blade which obviously you can't do
with the actual gun
i think that a lot of these stasis
teasers are like that
okay a little over the top yeah they're
kind of soft enough to target first
okay okay well we see it makes it good
it makes sense
you know it could very well be you know
not as
crazy for and for balance purposes let's
be real that would be a little bit more
fair
you know in that in that sandbox but if
you combine like when the titan slams
the warlock comes in and goes boom
yeah at the end of the day
team synergy is going to be fire like
that that's control is going to be a
mess
yes clash like everybody's running
around trials everybody's like
pretty orchestrated and smart about
their stuff but control just oh
blueberries on control points i see bad
news written all over that
especially if you're just like running
together and be like everybody's on b
frozen shattered six person kill oh crap
mm-hmm
people are going to be getting some very
fun medals i think out of this stuff as
well
oh yeah oh yeah it's good it's going to
be like i said i can't wait for mayhem
can't wait for certain little modes just
to and the key is going to be
the competitive scene you know how do
these things play out in compact comp
how does it play out in trials you know
what messy combinations people come up
with like
that's where it's gonna get interested
yeah um i don't know pvp the sandbox
definitely is about to get probably the
biggest shakeup it's had in
ever maybe speaking of which
do we want to touch rumors
of sandbox reasoning behind sandbox
shakeups
oh maybe
not okay okay maybe if we do
damn how
i don't want to put him in any position
so apparently what's the catch of the
bag what'd you say
i'm sorry can you say it clearly can you
say it clearly
for the people outside we didn't quite
catch it please
what what what's happening yes hot
what's happening
i think i'll leave that to you
can i talk discreetly start yeah like
okay so basically i guess the idea is
we know the destiny vault content vault
is coming we know things are be putting
in there
i guess the idea is there seems to be
have been discussion is the best vague
way i can say it
the reason for the vault there may be
more reasons for the vault than we
expect
right is that the best way i can phrase
that without totally butchering at all
the fans ain't listening we good we good
so the whole thing
the feds ain't listening
the consensus you know was that um
there's a possibility that
the ball you know has a secondary
purpose
and the secondary purpose is streets is
watching
y'all stupid in the chat but it's like
you know
the purpose being not just because the
the what was told to us was space
space right this game's getting big
games getting big call of duty is the
one
i will definitely say call of duty is
the one thing now granted they can just
be call of duty and be like i don't care
you're going to make it work
but call of duty is twice the size of
destiny about i mean it's 165 gig
potentially what they had it could be
bigger
it's not a small game and dusty is not
that big now space for them to manage
like bugs and number of areas and it's a
different type of game
that would have been more of the valid
argument but if you're talking about
like hard drive space
that's just a preference of what game
you play but it's always been one of
those that
has always kind of been a question to me
as opposed to
if they're like now when they say the
debugging and testing weapons in 1200
different places takes so long and
testing is
so much slower because we have all these
spaces that was the piece that always
made sense to me
right but we have kind of another
possible
reason thought process so basically you
know for those that don't know that's in
the chat
you know the thought process is now that
instead of it just being a space
issue whereas you know we always
complain you know
why things take so long to fix you know
this is so buggy what's going on
and there is another thought process
that actually when these things are
vaulted that
they are actually being rebuilt engine
wise
thus them not having the need for a
destiny 3
because when these things go away the
the thought process is that they will be
reworked completely
then brought back and then that's the
new engine
so to speak i mean and that's we
literally speculated about this before
you and i have talked about this like
verbatim so if this is something that's
actually happening
we technically talked about it just
maybe with a total loss to it
we're good we're just honestly just
talking generally because we don't want
to pick a side on
the community obviously a bit on the
information and how it was dispersed but
the issue is like like
he said perfect we've talked about this
we last word was ahead of the game i'm
just like you know we were talking
because that's that voice again
before everybody told me that's my man
right there so anyway
we're good so at the end of the day it
plausible did not give a deal
at the end of the day you know i think
if the rumors are earmuffs buffs
if the rumors are true this is dope this
now
resolves the issue that we always had
that the engine needs to be updated why
don't y'all fix
right now this is actually the result of
it and from what we're hearing
it could come back quicker than we think
you know it's not might not be as long
shout out to paul tassie which i could
talk about that's this is public
information
public information we gotta cheat you
like lois i'm like
we gotta get you in on this in a second
let's just honor him to finish this
sentence you know so
public information paul tassie has an
article right now discussing it and
um yeah like everybody has their
theories in reference to it
in this whole thing and i i think if all
this is true
this is cool and we get to revitalize
this game but i'm gonna pass it over to
hop
you know what you're thinking now that
all this
potential stuff is out in the in the
universe
it's definitely no longer in the ether
it's real so yes yes
yes what do you think hop
it depends on how accurate the
information is
uh what can change me right so this
could be an old philosophy
but no longer guys we just don't know
until they officially
say something valid point valley point
by the point
it's like i will say when they're
thinking about at some point
i mean whether that's the jokes about
spaghetti code whether bungie said it or
whatever
there's a lot of things that happen when
you switch weapons but your projectile
is still affected by the weapon you're
not even equipped right now there's
there's some things in the game that
obviously people have seen the way they
break the game stuff of that nature
when they look at stuff like cross play
talking across systems and platforms the
better their
code base is the better off like the
whole game's going to be so if they do
need time to
you know rework stuff if it is happening
maybe they're starting on a smaller
scale of reworking as we joked like
how like if you have to rework the whole
game or half the game
okay it's a lot easier to work on half
the game one new destination make a
little more manageable size
if there's any credence to this at all
like if they're if it's valid
even partially it makes sense for the
future they're going for full cross play
across all platforms
smoothing out the code making everything
work a little bit better together
um i think it's got potential and it's
one thing that
whether it's like completely because of
these reasons it's probably something
they feel like they may have to do no
matter what the vault just may be part
of it we just don't know all of it
right and one last point i want to add
on to what you're saying is that
one thing that we saw when we we did the
12 last
last last word you know one thing we did
say was like
man that's a lot of content we're losing
right
man that's a lot of strikes we're losing
so if it is you know true
then these things are getting rework it
would make sense it would make sense
because you you've got to take a lot of
chunks out you you've got to
i mean even the uh some of the the the
missions and the
special missions and the forge we were
like why is that going that you know
that kind of stuff and
all of this could potentially you know
be reworked and
in that regard i would have no problem
so
basically the theory is that beyond
light
in a sense is is d3 in a sense with that
because this new let's be real this new
stuff looks
sandbox changing we have to
stasis look like it this is looking like
they are
really going all out as far as affecting
and manipulating the environment
so i didn't think this was possible with
the with the current
thing if you if you told me how if you
just show me stasis i'm like how are
they going to implement that
but now we take this theory into effect
and let's just say this is the newer
version of said engine
right and newer tools that allow them to
freeze and do all this great crazy
fortnite walls and all this kind of
stuff
it kind of makes sense it kind of makes
sense but we'll see we'll see this is
what you think about i heard you
chirping like you know you thinking that
possibly maybe beyond light is a newer
version
of of the of the engine
as i tend to say with a lot of things in
dev
it's too early to speculate um i i was
giggling when you said fortnite was
because i just brought it back
concept is fascinating but i think it is
true
that the capability of change if you
look at
the war mind live events when all might
be another
like the one mighty crash right they
couldn't have done that a year ago
so it shows that their systems are
evolving
valid absolutely valid i forgot about
that
yeah and that's the first time they
tried that and
at the time they said we are testing new
technology
you know i know we're working out the
kinks but you're right and it could set
up potential for a lot more things this
is this is interesting
it's very like i said uh like hop you
said it best
we're all speculating here things could
change we don't know for sure
right but at the end of the day if true
you know this this is very exciting and
this definitely
you know quells my little anxieties
about
having a number a new number at the end
of destiny
when these things could potentially be
implemented if true
i mean that's kind of what we almost
have to think about this is a soft d3
because i mean what would happen if we
got a d3 you'd wipe the slate completely
clean
if we got a new numbered game buy a new
game everybody starts fresh
so we're keeping some stuff but we're
bringing you know some stuff forward but
we're starting new things new abilities
it's like a soft d3 so if they gotta
innocence purge half the game
right to get to a point where this is
like where we're gonna go from a
you know place moving forward it kind of
makes sense
yeah like soft d3 vanilla right like
and later on you know and it kind of
adds up there's some tea leaves that do
kind of add up with it so now the other
question i want to get red eye here was
asking this is one i thought about too
when is the point where they leave past
gen consoles behind how far
we got which queen we got lightfall how
far do they go
before they embrace next-gen and as
we've talked about before
like the destiny map specifically drive
through your little cave unload the area
behind you load the next
i mean those are loading zones just
disguised as like drive-through zones
when is the point where it's like is it
a true like post lightfall
light versus dark that way they can
build a game that
uses the new ssds and that point when do
you guys see
them embracing like okay old consoles
we're not updating anymore
or is it just the number that does it
because what was it rise of iron they
left something behind right
yeah my family left behind 360 and ps3
yes that's a good point um i'll jump in
i i think
i think honestly they could do it i want
to say anytime they want but i think
they have a lot of control
my guess is this is going to be a pure
financial business decision
and it's going to be it's going to
mirror once the next generation
population base
is up to stuff to then make the break
because right now we're still in that
cross-generational period there's still
way too many more people with ps4s
and xbox ones so they're waiting for the
adoption rate that to raise up
right and then once that goes up and you
have that line then most of the
community has transferred over
unless you know budget they all about
they metrics they know who's playing
what how's playing what
so i think that you know maybe if it's
maybe by witch queen
you know by then the numbers are there i
think it will be a situation like
i think hop your you're completely right
i think it will be a
another september slash novembery
expansion time they tend to do their
biggest
um you know migration so to speak during
those type of moments
so i think if it's not which queen
definitely buy the next one it will be
which will be what 2022
the light phone yeah it's got to be
audited
i think at that point they just cannot
continue to support
justify supporting the old one and then
really take this
engine to the next level especially if
the intention
is not to put a number on it so fast
because they keep complying
you know we're going to be here for a
while with d2
but what do you think pop
i think that the intent is more than
likely to keep going with d2
uh although technical limitations may
hold them back
i think lightfall is when we're going to
see them shed the old
generation of consoles
music to my ears
love it keep preaching dana was saying
something especially since it's free
d2 is d free right now if they do a d3
that probably wouldn't start free would
it because like the free contents like
the way to bring new people in
after it's been out for a little while
that's what i'm saying i don't think
that they're going to go to
t3 yeah because you already have an
existing
platform right so they're going to adopt
the round model
keep the graphics keep the assets
looking the same
and just keep going with it hey listen i
don't mind as long as they get rid of
that
that common denominator the lowest
common denominator i'm fine
yeah as long as certain consoles get
their walking papers
i'm fine i'm fine you can keep you the
number doesn't mean
anything to me unless certain people is
not allowed in the club anymore let me
stop
oh man here like it could say d not one
two three it doesn't matter as long as
it looks pretty
your
xbox one vcr and that
playstation 4 base like yeah we got we
gotta have a cutoff point at some point
so
what about you what are you thinking i
mean it's
it's one of those where we've talked
enough about like the idea of if it's
if it's technical if they're held back
by technical limitations of
old gen or anything like that however
they have to make that switch to
get to a make destiny a next generation
style game like
whether it's map design whether it's
number of enemies whether it's like ai
programming because they can use the new
cpus
whatever all those pieces are whether
they put a two a three a one
a destiny with a colon and an x-ray i
don't care like
i just don't want them to hang too long
on the old stuff because
you know if it's like three or four
years later and it still feels like
destiny with like here's the map here's
your drive-through zone like to load the
next area true
more open world has a lot of potential
and i would love i can't wait for them
to embrace it so the faster they do that
the better for
my happiness just to
evolve the game i just don't know if you
know
here's europa here's this zone drive
through this little ice canyon here's
this one go through this cave and if
it's
or if it's just like here's a big giant
open sheet of ice
you can drive over here here here and
there's no like obvious in between
loading zones and it feels different
that's that's what i look forward to or
at least hope at some point is happening
but again those are more dreams at this
point until we see how things run
i'm with you bro i'm with you man it's
gonna take a while for all these
developers to actually start using the
ssds in the consoles and actually build
stuff that's like
fully into it so it'll it'll be some
time now what do you guys think on next
gen you're looking forward to the most
whether it be
higher frame rates if you play on
console
that's all it was it's just the giant
grin
um if they implement ray tracing into
destiny 2 what that would look like
uh what next is you know if you guys are
on an
og xbox or ps4 how about those loading
times like what do you think people are
gonna be
probably either the most surprised by or
kind of enjoy the most
i think
think hey the voting times of course
that has been a huge way to entry or
obey it to
enjoying the game fully on console
secondary level
i think if we be opens the field in
terms of what they can design
i think they're gonna have more options
with the higher power
that these new consoles provide
yeah yeah i mean nvme
brother nvme you showed me the light i
talked to uh
offline i was talking to uh the fire
team chat and we were all talking about
um you know just as far as like how
we're planning for beyond light
and you know shout out to trav i mean he
was like look i'm on x he was like i'm
still
in the mud at 30 frames and he's just
like my brother
when you get that 60 and you get that
envy of me
because dustin was like yeah i left him
i went over to peace
and i said that's it i feel you you know
so i said i blame i told him i literally
said it right in his face i said i blame
me bartus for my [ __ ]
i said if it wasn't for him i would have
never had my pinky in the air
i would have never been this way i left
my 80 of my clam
and i had no problems doing it
because i said until you understand the
finer thing i have my callus
my callus cup until you understand this
field of view and this 60 frames and
this nvme
like it was so bad black wings i'm sorry
brother i know you're not og vcr i know
but here's the thing that's even harsh
because the vcr is dating it that much
more
it's like a double it's like a double
shot like oh you got the ogx box
vcr i was like this over oh
i was like this over a pc i was like man
until you get that loaded speed
man it's just it's beautiful man it's
you you just can't go back
you just want to find the thing so just
have my console brothers
finally get that it is such a
quality of life improvement like you
have no idea i remember just being in
orbit hop
right i would go to the fridge get
sandwiches i would
i would go take a bathroom break and i
still ain't loading into the map yet
or console right but now with all of
this stuff
and then now you're talking ray trait
man oh
it's going to be transformative people
are going
destiny's going to feel like a new game
to these people
for us we've been living the good life
we've been drinking we had our caviar we
good
but for them
you're black reporting out for [ __ ]
don't really matter
hey man i gotta talk about it i gotta
talk about it man but it's gonna be fun
like all jokes aside
really fun just have this tech for the
masses like
super fun salute the clown
oh clowns my brother man clowns don't
even like destiny so i have clouds in
here
absolute clown you gotta you got no
excuse man it's you
you're on xbox it's 3.99 brother come
join up we got room in the clan for your
clowns
you can put your vision down ain't no
contact
it seems like you're literally clowning
him right now but that's just his name
oh my god
clowns are my god that's like i love
clowns man that's my guy right there
good dude really good doing the
community
so how long have you been on pc from
xbox when did you make that switch or
have you been on pc
okay wow how did that how did that feel
because that's actually fairly recent
um it took a little bit to get
accustomed to
but now i am
at a competitive level on pc wait i'm
still not there on
controller like with m k i'm just
dramatically better than the amount of
controller
oh so so you advise people that
typically use controller they might want
to check out mnk
try both see what's more comfortable and
then master that
fair enough fair enough i like the pc
answer
so this is the the reason that i'm
giving a modern answer is because
destiny
how can i put this that means
destiny cheats for you on both inputs
yes
yes and it sheets for you in different
ways
so you have to see which one fits best
for you
no that's 100 like the idea of like aim
assist and bullet magnetism and all that
stuff that is
a lot of behind the scenes work unless
you get into the nitty-gritty like
the mercury's and spreadsheets and
details and like all the testing and
stuff a lot of people don't know and
they just go by feel so i mean that
makes perfect sense i was just giving
cocktail a hard time
i know you he loved your answer oh no
believe me i've had people on the
podcast i'm the only one over here on
mouse and keyboard i'm like you guys
have fun
yeah i've been lucky that the guest
we've had at the campfire have been
i think a little bit more controller
base but the reality is
the majority of pc destiny players are
playing every case
yeah i mean it's a natural setup there's
certain games like
go sushima i was playing mortal shell
those are going to be on controller
no question just the way i have access
to a lot of inputs in one hand
but the the dexterity of a mouse for
aiming for me has still always been
i've been doing first person shooters on
pc since
my pc could barely function like so many
so many years ago so
it's a normal thing to me but to switch
like if you've just been first person on
console for so long it's it's a drastic
change and it may like be detrimental
but if you if you made the switch in a
year though and now you're at a
competitive level that's
solid you've been definitely putting in
the work yes to be fair
so i was competitive and overwatch on pc
before that
okay so this is my first time using mk
this is the moving timing
for destiny ah so you've got some skills
on it already i see
i see she flexing she can be like
i'm just you know
how many fallout crowns you got as well
just start gonna like you lining them up
over there on a shelf
like this yeah
none so i've been having my own tim the
chapman situation where i'm like
almost level 20. and i have not won a
single match
uh how do you have like
decent amount of fun or final rounds
just can't have you been like inches
away or is it just like not coming
together yet
inches oh i can get to the final round
almost consistently but i can't win
oh that's even worse if you've been
there that many times
which one which one do you like the most
for the end like there's the hexagon
jumping i've seen there's like the
mountain you climb
what is your like what's your what's the
struggle what's the hardest struggle to
end on
uh someone is a pain in the ass because
even though you have a perfect route
a bunch of other people have it too yeah
so it's like kind of if you run one
round you're perfect you're set for the
entire thing
um hexagon is my favorite
for sure that one i would say is the
most like platform
skill can you time the jumps can you can
you be persistent enough to make it
through but if you like
if you're on that top level and you do
so and you miss one you're like
you've missed like eight floors later on
you're like
wait for it oh yeah that game was so fun
to watch
i got to stop playing the fun i see you
guys having it's just
did you see the season two it looks like
absolute chaos because instead of like
running through doors
now as a like an uncoordinated group you
have to like
push these objects up to get and hop
over the wall oh
there's so many more things you have to
like move as a group i was like oh it's
going to be so much worse
oh it's going to be a nightmare it's
yeah it's chaos fun
you can't take it too seriously but yeah
the the tim the tatman thing was
hilarious to watch that was
and i will say the guy who runs the fall
guys twitter guy or girl whoever it is
they are on fire
she is such a challenging community
manager oh
absolutely just out of nowhere just
absolutely crushing i think he had like
a couple rough days but
when they embraced it oh so good
there was one point they were saying hey
you could play against some bots and
then maybe you could win i think when
they were giving tim the tatman some
hell
oh it was so brutal oh yeah
i was like they're taken after the
wendy's community manager
you guys have ever seen wendy's on
twitter oh my god they will roast
everyone and everything and not give two
craps about it it's so good
the the community manager was a youtuber
prior to coming to do this
so here's a little bit of experience of
breaking the crowd building
community nice etc
yeah it's a lot of fun but yeah that's
so it's kind of a nice like breath if
you're playing something heavy
just to be like bing bing just like get
into crazy jumping bean mode so
mm-hmm yeah um i feel like we have so
it's these weird days like oh we get
this huge trailer all the stuff and we
like
knock we have this weird thing about
this podcast there could be nothing
happen and we'll go off on these
tangents for like two and a half hours
and then i feel like as we wrap this one
up we're like not even two hours in and
i was like
i feel like we went in depth on the
characters talked about all it's so
weird oh it's so
weird like the shows where we sit there
we
actually will say you know the old joke
was because we recall flashpoint before
uh right so the joke was like oh it
ain't gonna be a flashback it's gonna be
a long point because we're gonna be
talking it's gonna be live
and then like those shows we tend to
like
boom boom boom boom and we're like wow
we finished kind of quickly on time
and then it shows we like there was
nothing going on what are we going to
talk about
those will have like the most in-depth
you know deep conversation and it goes
long and we're just like
we have this we have this weird synergy
like that it's fun like
it's hilarious to see sometimes it's
kind of funny
yeah like shout out to do right he said
like last week last time it was the food
tangent right yeah literally came out of
nowhere
shout out together half hour talking
about food my picky eating which we
don't need to bring up again
uh okay quick discussion gotta know
where you fall and
cognito and i are not gonna say anything
do you hawkmoon is supposed to be coming
back
i almost made him spit out his coffee oh
yeah we did that's right yeah we did
so yeah so so as i said but chad can
hear it
yup if you do hockman well if it's a
good weapon
i'm happy with it you say [ __ ] it up
i'm not gonna show it it's very simple
it's like
if you're going to bring it back to it
right if you don't i'm upset
i love it simple plain play
pressure's on luke
mayhawk mood yeah just don't f it up and
hawk moon's happy about it that's the
key
uh for the other weapons though did you
guys see kind of the red and blue
aesthetic on some of the weapons
getting a feel for those do you guys
like the way those look
they're definitely unique i'm getting
i'm getting normal
kind of vibes i'm getting kind of you
know i'm hearing what clovis is
something i'm here i don't know i'm
hearing
like it a little red you know what it
reminds me of
remember um like palindrome
is like white with like a green handle
like yellow bucket but yeah the palette
it was like the old
uh like d1 crucible weapons for one of
those years was
like completely that color for sure
going to that vendor
in the tower the old tower you know
where you would go to shax's robotic
handler
and he'd have palindrome and all those
other little guns that had that kind of
shader and that art style
it that it was like kind of like a a
blue
and uh what is it what's the other
colors are we gonna say that's like a
not a red is it what is it where's the
combo or palindrome what was the
the the color combo i feel like it was
kind of that almost
it was blue and orange orange yeah
almost
yeah so the closest to this that we've
had was
destiny one year ones crucible vendor
gear
was this red and blue
i agree i agree well they stand out for
sure because you have like the dark
armor with like the little
neon visor lights and then on the dark
arm they're holding these like bright
blue and red weapons
they look fairly cool all of them look
quite unique i've got to be
kind of curious i know we saw one pulse
one looks like a giant rocket launcher
possibly a sidearm
i'm still committed to the first thing
we saw as we saw it again as a shotgun
since it's the only thing that would
have that big of a barrel um
overall they look pretty cool now
obviously they show us five weapons
we have so many things leaving the game
in sunsetting for effectiveness like you
know you go
avoid bow don't have one of those the
subtle calamities going away
outside of obviously lame and arc but
there's i'm very curious how big the
arsenal comes with beyond light because
this is the first time we're really
getting sun setting for in-game stuff
if there's not say like a void bow it's
like literally an archetype that doesn't
exist for in-game
so if you want to go into if you want to
use a bow in nightfalls
and you need a void you can't so i'm
kind of curious how they fill some of
the holes
with what's going to be usable in
in-game activities if they hit them all
or they're just like
all right now we'll get to them later
i'm very first
i think this is where your your sun
setting actually has an advantage
because they
they can now look at the archetypes you
know
as a whole and and fill in what they
need to kind of bring in to even out
you know what's what's uh deficient so
yeah i actually i'm not actually worried
about this i actually think that um
in this case that they will bring in
introduce a bunch of legendaries that
are going to
you know fill that spot and also i know
they're going to be sneaky that's my
other theory
is that a lot of the weapons that i
don't want to say were broken but were
problematic
right for example mountaintop we know
and stuff like that for them
you know now we're getting what's the
energy one that
that's kind of out right now that's like
a mountaintop
exactly so i think this is where they
kind of will introduce
similar things newer foundry new weapon
thing but
not as potent this is a way
sandbox about this thing in a way you
can bring it back
and but just introduce it in a way that
you they they know that they went
a little bit too out of control and
stuff like that but
i'm also kind of hoping it takes the
it takes the way they build the
encounters over stuff that's not as op
having to deal with like your
mountaintops and quick reloads and then
anarchies on top of mountaintops like
the amount of damage that sometimes
people can output gets to be crazy
and if that stuff's not viable in in the
end game
they've got a way to balance encounters
to a different level which i'm very
curious to see how that feels
yeah um absolutely fun time i mean for a
while i mean recluse mountaintop
anarchy like that's so much of in-game
stuff
that was a loadout so back to those
destination weapons
do you think that or back to the red and
blue weapons yeah the question is do you
think their destination weapons
do you think they're from an activity oh
good question
because they have a different aesthetic
than the armor so it's possible
but they might be like some sort of
public event or some sort of activity
that exists
on your buffer i was like my thoughts on
the color scheme
i don't think they would show the raid
weapons yet but the deep stone crate
definitely jumping yeah i was like i
don't think they're raid but they do
like the deep stone crypt has the reds
and like the blue lights and it has that
tonal look to it
so while it looks like it may go in
there that i definitely don't think
they're showing them
uh i don't know i would i wish
escalation protocol yes yep that's what
i was about like
altars of sorrow like if they have like
a set that comes from
an activity like that i would that'd be
awesome i really hope they
do that more because we only got like
three from altars of sorrow on that kind
of rotation i'd love to see like a full
set that comes from something like that
that'd be cool
i'd really like to see that actually
absolutely
absolutely yeah this is this is this is
fun
this is this is a fun time i'm excited
you know and the cool the cool thing
about it
hop and eat i love is that right now
let's be honest
it's a it's a slow time right but
yo that laugh you don't tell us how you
really feel
i laugh jesus what he's like
at the end of the day what's cool is
between
i love the fact that they i'll be honest
i didn't think we were going to be
getting
you know these content drops these
informational pieces
so now to get us you know each segment
of the way
as we get closer to november that's
gonna ease the pain
of things not being around to do in the
game
but i will say this that last 12
definitely put let the fire set fire on
me
i got to get stuff done i gotta get a
couple of catalysts finished
i gotta get things done because there's
something you
need and i cannot not be without
or not knowing the fate of when they're
gonna return so
yeah i'm on my sleeper grind i'm on my
i'm gonna be on my um my raid stuff
getting stuff done so we got time but
it's cool now we get in
you know they're giving us release dates
like yo you're going to get the
tightness there you're going to get the
like i like that you know so it's
exciting man this is
this is the fun part of destiny and i
like to see
like i said a center five team chat they
really knocked it out the park with the
marketing
and kudos to them because if the rumors
are true you know
looking at stasis is exciting
i like them getting this crazy like this
regardless if it's broken or not we love
it we've been saying they're too stale
like this
is fun stuff i'm enjoying it i'm
enjoying what i'm saying i'm very
curious what the stasis shields look
like on enemies
like because we're going to have stasis
weapons which we haven't even seen yet
but if you have stasis as an element
unless it just functions in a very
different way there's also going to be
enemies like potentially some of the
fallen
that have like a stasis shield that we
have to break with stasis weapons
so yeah so if you went to the um
the titan gameplay from the b-roll it
shows one of those faces shields it's
like a
whitish blue okay yeah
i was curious how much it would be
distinct from like the arc shield right
now i guess i gotta go definitely it
doesn't look like eric
okay cool it looks the color of snow
pretty much yeah yeah so all these
little elements now you
that's one of those things too you go
into a nightfall it's like how many
shields can they put in there because
now we got four different types you
can't hit them all you even with your
subclass and stuff and
osmosis i think is the one i'm thinking
of yeah
yeah you definitely can't hit them all
so i'll be curious like how
crazy some of these encounters get so
it's a lot to be excited for
it's also it is as you said it feels
like it's a long ways away because i
know i chuckled
yeah it's not it happened but i mean
that's one of those things it works now
because i am kind of dabbling in some
other stuff because we do have this
downtime but it's also when you remind
of like
all these catalysts and stuff that you
got to do i believe i can't like dabble
in other stuff too long because i'm
going to lose that window
because there's if you go through that
checklist unless you're just like
you know completionist and you're
already done but if you have a decent
list of stuff to do some of it's going
to take like world line zero
if you haven't started that that's five
weeks weeks uh i mean if you're looking
for your outbreak perfected it's
three uh so i mean there's certain ones
that are just time
whisper of the worm if you want the ship
that's gonna be another set of weeks so
like there's some stuff if you wait to
like hey i gotta crunch this in the last
week you're out so some of the stuff you
got to start
sooner than later because just the
number of weekly rotations to go through
is not going to be there
now they did say a couple little patch
notes as well just to cover with you
guys just because
most of it was about beyond light
talking about all that stuff um
but they did say a couple patch notes
they said the ornamental glows
they said they didn't like live up to
what was advertised they're looking at
revisiting those that
in a patch that's going to come on
september 8th which is good
and i think that's the end of the event
so you might have to commit to buy them
before you actually get to see what they
look like in game which is
kind of an odd date thing um so the
promise is there hopefully they
they say they should live up to more of
what they look like which is good
i even had like my white glow on like my
warlock gauntlets
full super it was just like the white
vein no glow coming out of the wrist and
i was i looked at a couple different
classes there were pieces
that had nothing and i'm like really all
this
and then for that so that's like i had
done the master work objective and they
just weren't going it's very odd
um so hopefully that's fixed they also
said if you're going for some completion
and stuff the sleeper nodes
those are going away some people are
trying to hit all 40
and they said they are working on
september 8th some like duplicate
protection
and if you're in a zone that's so useful
yeah the duplicate protection bad luck
protection whatever they call it but
they also say
if you're in a zone where a sleeper node
if you need a sleeper node in a certain
zone
and you know where it's at if you're not
in that zone you have a better chance of
it spawning because it won't spawn one
where you're standing
so they give you some kind of guidance
to try and get the ones that you're
going for because people have been
open like three or four hundred nodes
and not got the one they need because
it's random
because some random so they give like a
little kind of like a
let's say cheat sheet but a tutorial on
how to kind of get the numbers in your
your factor your way to get something
different in the sequence
yeah they also mentioned this for like
the frozen spawning gambit they're
looking at fixing this is all september
eight so we got about a week and a half
um the 80s on cold denial has a
different zoom
uh or the ads felt different that's
going to change on the ornament
uh yep they said uh the issue where the
ads on cold denial season pass ornament
was different than the weapon model
because fallout said
it looked like just the zoom was a
little more or something it was just a
different view on 80s
it's like hand cannon level zoom on the
ornament
whereas it's more of a normal post cycle
without it
so they're going to be fixing that uh
they're putting rhetoric's broadsword
back into collections so that will get
fixed
but question frederick's is that
isn't that still gonna get sunset yes
it's for the idea that people who had it
and deleted it
you can't pull it from collections right
now got you that was why see
like if people had cleaned it up
thinking hey it's a pursuit weapon just
like 21
delirium they can't go get it even
though they earned it okay
uh they said spider will be offering
three weekly wanted adventure bounties
up from one which is good because
sometimes that rotation's rough if
you're trying to do i think it's
chronicler
uh or wayfair one of the two notes wafer
i think um
if you need one specific ghost and one
specific mission
and some people can go the whole week
and not see it so hopefully that'll help
fix that one and then they said
merciless the exotic perk wasn't
working the merciless is gonna be fixed
to actually fire
faster upon not killing something those
are a little preview and bugs but i did
want to mention the glows because that's
going to be before solstice ins you got
to commit
but if you like i might buy them for one
class i don't know if i can give it to
all three
i don't know if i can spend 45 bucks on
glows but one set to give them a little
bit
yeah absolutely i might embrace the
titan set so i just bought it
and then it was fun in the uh
and trials and then i'll be done yeah
trials i got to hit up aries
and one of my other buddies couple
slowly work through those wins
and then uh i need to do a nightfall i
did
it's so funny like aries and if we need
to go run pit we're like got half an
hour cool
this pit is so fast now and i still
remember i mean doing it solo
doing it solo it's like yeah i gotta go
slow and patient but with like
with one other person there i can be a
lot more careless man we fly through
that one now
um but yeah that's mostly it we like so
we do have a patch coming on the 8th
2.92 kind of our last little preview
before
but other than that that might be
probably one of the last ones before
festival so september is going to be
that open
month of marketing go work on your old
stuff
that's like that's that's september it
feels like absolutely
do you have hop do you have anything on
your list that you
like any you know destiny 2 bucket list
before they go away
catalyst exotics anything that you
haven't done
i still need to finish update
you and me both actually i think i've
covered everything content-wise now it's
just
plain to enjoy there's something that's
getting
sunsets that i have to do nice
nice for me it's uh you know
reads and a couple other things i see
cat daddy in there one of my clan mates
yeah we will be linking up man i'll be
getting stuff done once things finally
calm down for me it's a little crazy
but um yeah i definitely get stuff done
and i'll just you know
get my my catalyst done and i just want
to get all my archetypes ready
ducks in a row so i have every option i
have
come beyond light just in case that meta
shifts you know your boy gotta be meta
ready gotta be meta ready so whatever
they
decide to do i've hopefully have you
know good
things options for each scenario each
archetype
i actually enjoy that part of destiny
like when things
you know hopefully scouts scouts
yeah you know what i'm saying speaking
of which i
i finally work i got my borealis um
catalyst
and i'm like yo borealis is really good
like i've never really used it
but i'm like could you imagine it is
super strong
it's super strong an ionic thing break
the shield and i'm like
i i'm mad i didn't use it when snipers
were actually
buffed and powerful because that thing
is a nightfall
like i'm like just breathing yeah
it's just bringing in a question do you
think high blade and boyalist gets
stasis
and i wondered about that somebody asked
that and they were also saying how long
is it going to take to rotate to the
element that you want
question wow i didn't think about that
i don't know do you think it would just
intrinsically be like oh let me load my
new ammo in or do you think you have to
do like
a little hard light borealis little baby
like one mission quest to
to get the new ammo working or something
do you think they'd go that far
don't already have catalysts
both already have catalysts so yeah so
you kind of have it in
the catalyst to add these stasis
that's interesting i don't know if they
ain't gonna go the extra mile and
put it in it may be not
useful in medusa i don't know well then
you should just sunset that exotic
whole show made it through i had to you
you teed that one up it was too easy
i did want to ask you guys though when
we see one of the speaking of like how
we get some of the new stuff
i don't know if it's a little tease but
how we get our stasis powers
we don't we seem to like talk to the
stranger a little bit
um but it does seem like the one little
like
social tent it's all i'm gonna call it
because it's this little like
camouflage like drapery over it there's
one little door but sitting in front of
it you've got
aeris the drifter and uh the stranger
sitting on a campfire like
if we actually get to interact with all
three npcs on one destination
we never have that many in one place
that is correct
i'm hoping they all have their own
little like era says go do this stuff go
look at the pyramid
stranger's like hey go over here piss
off the fallen get their stasis powers
drifter mess stuff i don't know but i
was like i
i'm very curious if we get to interact
with all three because they're sitting
around the campfire which is
kind of cool yeah yeah this is um
it's always cool that when they use
multiple
npcs in like trailers and stuff like
that and then
obviously we not only do we have that
going on we got to see where they go
with um
mr zavala after we had gamma trap on
yeah
another chapter of what you know his his
potential turn
um yeah i'm excited i mean listen it's
gonna be fun
drift is hilarious you know eris is the
wild card
we all love the stranger as far as just
the mystery and where the story is going
to go and
it's going to be fun i am really looking
forward to that's why
yes it's just the three odd
it just they don't three non-musketeers
they don't
they're they're all the three outsiders
castaway exiles like the only thing you
the only other one you need is osiris
sitting in there and you're good but
they're so anti-van the anti-vanguard
because if you picture like
cade whether he's a little commit comedy
guy he's still the hunter vanguards of
allah and accora
they are like the exact opposite so i'm
so curious what the story does
anti-banger they like it made it up who
knows
what i mean it's like you know the trio
and it's like and they all seem to kind
of have some piece of the darkness like
aerys is
who knows where she's at the stranger
seems to be with like stasis and then
you've got the drifter with
the the darkness and the taken and all
that stuff so they all seem to be
embracing kind of the other side
and i wonder if they're almost like a
preview because you're saying a stasis
or a darkness power
what if with the witch queen we have
some kind of taken abilities and then
the final
thinking and then with like lightfall we
might see whatever heiress has been
holding forever or maybe we get aerises
with
like somewhere between those two like we
get the last two and they're like a
preview of what we might get to mess
with
so so is this feeling stasis and it'll
be online if you have chili
if you thought she was really nice
that's right yeah
eris yes oh yeah that's right that's
right that's right
so heirs could be potentially stasis
i wonder what the stranger would offer
then she's time just
mess with time right yeah
you gotta see this a lot of questions
i just want to know what happens in the
next five years of destiny right now
come on just tell me
give it to us seriously there's so much
i just wish i could know where this
thing's going because they have so much
built right now
man they got a lot to execute on but
it's got so much potential
i guess it's good they never going to
run out of stories to tell
but that's about all i got you guys got
anything else you want to talk about
cover
as i said we did three hours and half of
that was food and this one we burned
through all the topics so
oh good we are caught up man like i said
oh hold on this i'm
probably gonna get the right answer so
hop
quick question high quality steak
say go to a steakhouse spend like 50 60
bucks
what is on that steak
or do you eat it uh yeah you can pick a
place
all right so cut out in l.a has a really
good waku
and um they serve it with an alcohol
sauce
a couple of other things um it's so good
it is really good so there's a sauce on
your steak
cook meaning well you know that's where
i cook
right so most of it
i do without the sauce but the sauce is
good to add something to it
you know what i i what sauce do you like
on your steak sir hold on there's a
difference she's talking about like a
hundred and fifty dollar plate probably
yeah
talking about like a two hundred dollars
you don't have to get into this business
no no i'm telling him i was like
i was even going like mid-range like
okay so
so hop went like four-star french
cuisine like crazy cooking i was at like
at least a
you know fine dining texas steakhouse
where the you know steak's gonna be at
least like 80 bucks
and i was asking him if he comes down
here and we go he's like yeah let me get
my a1 and i about fell out of my chair
so i was just curious your thoughts on
um fine dining steak and a1
you changed it over the best thing to
add
is whatever works for your palette
and it tastes better for you do it oh
man i don't like it
i'd probably go without it but if you
like it do it
is hop is walking that fence all day
just
listen there's no reason to be mad about
someone else's preferences
it's like not to sauce that is the
question
it is what it is you know i mean you
can't get back
the woman she appreciates a good sauce
every now and then
i don't agree like i'm not going to put
anyone on my steak
oh we always say said you said every
once in a while
right you you would have a sauce with
your your yeah but it's like
it wouldn't do anyone it would be it'd
be a sauce that's like homemade or
something
as long as a sauce is applied to that
steak that's all i care
that's all i can just condom it
condiments are good
like fine dining yeah it's like if you
get into like you know if you get into a
nice dish and some like high class
sauces but yeah the ketchup and the a1
yeah pass
i'll take my a1l but i'll take that
sauce victory
but yes that's yeah [ __ ] how dare you
yeah oh is your homemade sauce is fine
now crystal
you're coming around that was really
what yeah but if you do like a red wine
reduction not like wine and steak go
together
on top of that like that alone is a
pairing so that's one thing
listen i'm a bad child i put ketchup on
eggs
i i do all type of evil things i got to
mix it up man
masculine eggs
see now here's the thing i was like now
i'm going to get ruined because yeah i
don't i
yeah i eat a lot of stuff plain thing
everything is pretty like if i get a
hamburger it's meat and bread
or sometimes caramelized onions aren't
able to swallow that there's nothing
it's dry like no no see but if it's a
quality burger it better not be dry
okay so okay you need you need some
flavoring some some savoriness
no it means if it's a juicy well-cooked
burger and it's not a dry ass bun you
can eat a
beet and meat and bun burger now
yeah i don't do condiments i don't do
relish pickles
mayonnaise mustard ketchup none of them
frank
is you just a plain jane frank guy
oh my god my hot dogs are truly plain i
never put anything on a hot dog
that scene
hey hit me i'm here chad's loving it so
you got questions ask him
oh man is there any sort of condom
that you do like or do you just eat your
food dry
so it so like okay so if i do like
enchiladas i like a ranchero sauce
so i'll do like i like a red sauce um
i'm really picky about cheese that's a
whole like podcast in itself probably
uh if it's a burger if it's a burger the
most i will do
rarely a good cheese but if i do that i
gotta have bacon
uh i will do caramelized onions and say
like avocado
but i don't want like you know
chick-fil-a
sauce or ketchup or mayo or mustard none
of those
um and then no pickles got no pickles we
had this one before
ketchup like is it just like you you
kind of feel like when you have it
pickles are worse mustard's worse
ketchups ketchup's still tomato based
but i don't want it on that
on the food the food that it goes on i
don't want it on it do you have ketchup
on it
no i don't want i like tomatoes i will
eat
like a ranchero sauce i will eat a
marinara sauce but i don't like i don't
want ketchup on the food that it goes on
eve the ketchup has been vilified by
this man
maybe it's too maybe it's too much
growing up with like meatloaf and
ketchup on top didn't like the ketchup
who knows but
nah the destiny cooking show continues
demand a cheesecast all right cheese in
short order
i do not like liquid cheese so i don't
eat queso my wife loves queso so she
gets to enjoy all the queso which is
fine
uh i don't like cold cheese so like
shredded cold cheese or like you know
wedges of cheese on crackers no thank
you if i am gonna do cheese it has to be
melted but not liquid so like picture
pizza if you're gonna put it as a
topping on like an enchilada it melted
as it cooked over the top
or like and it definitely can't be a
cold piece of cheese on a burger that
thing has to be
melted and not american american ain't
cheese sorry
we oh to do a food podcast
well she said cheese casting i thought
it said cheesecake i'm like i can talk
about cheesecake i make cheesecake
that's different
oh me and him we have the truth his
cheesecake is the truth but my thing is
so what shadow though we can do channel
we can do the cheddar on the cheese we
do we is that is that allowed i will i
will do a bacon cheeseburger
all right so we we have but nothing else
on it that is that is as far as the
the the burger like caramelized onions
actually is kind of
i love caramelized onions like those are
a recent edition raw onions
no and that's a texture thing i don't
like raw onions in anything i like them
to be cooked
how do we go from how do we get on these
and then you guys have so many questions
it keeps going
i'm not that interesting i'm boring on
food so it shouldn't be that hard of a
discussion
the fact that you i'm not interested in
a lot of different food makes it
interesting
yes you guys like whatever ah you're
boring oh you have choices you make
oh we gotta talk
actually like something yeah i'll be
like you know he liked that on his food
okay wow this is okay
now spices seasonings yes
that's crucial obviously you gotta have
some flavor to your food but
okay we learned it's not just like
completely yeah it's like
a boiled chicken breast is this boring
to everybody like it's got to be
marinated it's got to be seasoned like i
love teriyaki i will do teriyaki on
lots of things like a hawaiian burger
even with a slice of pineapple on there
that's
i mean i'm i have my choices
how do you feel about spice i like spice
i actually do
i really like spice uh i don't need to
like be sweating from my eye
ears and eyes because of it um
but i will say like after living in
texas and like kind of growing
accustomed to some spices
yeah like i lived in wisconsin for about
a year and then versus like
even just texas version of tex mix salsa
up there that is tomato sauce down here
at least it might have a kick to it so
it's got to have something going on so i
definitely am like especially like
mexican food spice for sure it can't be
bland otherwise it is boring
well like indian spice guac growing
guac is growing on me i will
so now mostly now mostly i would prefer
just like
straight avocado plain without all the
other stuff in there
i will occasionally dabble but i like
the pure avocado
on something as opposed to like the
peppers and the onions and the jalapenos
and all the stuff in the guac too
i think i think i think your
taste buds at a younger age
were very resistant to this stuff
because i know when i was younger like i
didn't
i need fish i didn't eat a lot of things
when i was young and then as i got
older it became an acquired taste you
know what i'm saying i think for you
you may need to try some things you
formally rejected and see if you still
dislike them
i have tried some things over time half
the time because it's on accident when i
ask for a burger one way i get another
and bite and i'm like crap it's not
right
okay so it's like some of that stuff
i've tried out of not my choice just be
like
i get you know grabbing the food real
fast on the fly and they made it wrong
i'm like
and it's like literally half i haven't
even finished like closing my teeth and
i know it's wrong
if it's pickles i can smell it before it
gets there but everything else i gotta
half bite into
but as opposed for like new red barbecue
rub i would rather have a rub than
barbecue sauce
yeah but ribs are better than sauce
so like no and if barbecue sauce is on
there it can't be like
if gmt geek in here is probably losing
his mind i don't want it
slathered in sauce i would rather have a
little bit of sauce like
almost barely brushed on for the flavor
if it's a good sauce
but mostly the rub and the spice is what
i would prefer on the pan unlike salad
in my previous statement i think rubs
are better for ribs
for your brisket and serving texas
barbecues frosted away
so mine is the key it's got to be a good
enough brisket that you don't even need
sauce it's got to be juicy and cooked
well
that you don't need the sauce it's an
addition if you wanted airplanes you
need it the risk it is too dry
that i agree hundred percent he said i'm
going to team wrong
don't you can't uh spidey i wouldn't say
that out of context to other people
you're good right now that sentence
was spidey
back is over there it's like he put
barbecue sauce on his porterhouse steak
why
oh my god
see i'm like i would like something
cooked like merited in and cooked in but
like just
swimming in sauce probably none of the
stuff i mentioned
but yeah what is this fun that's the fun
to
oh it's so fun oh man you never do chips
with dip
never do that i do chips and salsa my
wife gives me so much
crap for the way i eat my chips i used
to just not eat salsa at all so it was
just
like chips and they just had to be
salted otherwise it was a little boring
now when i dip i'm okay so i saw on
twitter i'm not the only one
but i don't do the [ __ ] but i don't do
like a chip
i don't i don't scoop i dunk and then
bring it back out and kind of shake it
off so
that is the epitome of how i visualize
you
wow but yeah there's there's no scooping
sauce i don't want like the big
like no my wife just gets all the scoop
so i'll like thin out the sauce and she
can just scoop easy
looking for a shirt yo crystal
see i i saw i saw a poll on twitter and
somebody was like are you
are you are you dip or scoop and i was
like i'm a dip i want i like the flavor
now that's actually
something i've probably since i met my
wife i calm down so
yeah but i don't need i don't need a
bucket of tomatoes on top of my chip
oh i love it well see there we go four
cuddles he's a dipper
thank you i got a couple dips a couple
of different there's a lot of dippers in
here see you you need both in this life
you need some dippers to thin it out and
then you scoopers
you got this like thick tomato paste
almost coming up on your chip right
there
so hear me out if you dip into the scoop
what you get is you get your whole chip
in then you pull all the sauce out
and it's better than just a normal scoop
all right that's that's interesting i
like with like
chips and sauce and stuff i take so much
sauce
you're one of those like hey you may as
well bring like four but little cups of
salt i'm gonna go through it all
uh just drinking it over there
guys you gotta just eat the dip you're a
savage deal but
you we were going to put you on an
intervention sir
you have something what happened to you
i was a picky eater growing up asked my
mom where are you i'm talking to you
yeah some of you guys will drink the
salsa
avoid chips with a curved edges no i
don't care about the shape
that doesn't bother me i don't do
buffalo sauce either on wings
i don't do buffalo wings you don't do
the um
the the white sauce what is it that you
dipping me blue cheese hell no
i don't do ranch either the blue cheese
is liquid
well blue cheese is just gross oh my god
okay well blue cheese is an acquired
taste i know it's one of my favorites
but i also know that
a lot of people don't like it
interesting so you don't do buffalo
wings at all you just that's not even i
mean if i do them they're in either like
a barbecue or a teriyaki or rub but it's
definitely not like because whenever you
go spicy it's always like buffalo hot
mild crazy fire
you know fire engine diarrhea whatever
it is like i don't do
because it's i've learned a lot of it's
like vinegar based that i don't like
because salad dressings i don't like
therefore salad not a big thing i'll do
vegetables but not salad because i don't
like
most dressings or vinegar based so
that's one of those things as well
and that's why it's like if the vinegar
gets to be too potent i'm out
interesting interesting all right i
don't know how long these people want to
sit here and also if we should let
hoplite
get back to our world talking about food
i apologize about the uh departure
she may have enjoyed it though she had
questions so i'm i'm loving this like i
could go for another hour
she's like i must know all the food
things do you like this no
uh i know i said indian food at one
point and i feel like you picked up
i have tried one dish of indian food my
wife likes it she's kind of on board
she's made a couple curries
uh that is a whole different spice
palette
and that's what i'm like i'm like i am
not as used to that so i'm like i've
tried like she'll make it and i will try
it
not that big of a fan i think i tried
like chicken biryani which is like as
plain as that crap gets because it was
like chicken sitting under like a bucket
of rice
so there's no sauce um and the spices
there that was a way for me to like
kind of taste the spices on the chicken
but not embrace like it floating in some
you know curry sauce or anything like
that so it was like a dabble
that was kind of okay but like if it was
just like you know
chicken i'm trying what is the what is
like chicken tikka masala or something
like that and it's just floating nah
i'm probably not even i'm a little
scared to try that honestly
wow he's he's particular
[Laughter]
gordon over there is like all right so
we're going to put these eating habits
into a spreadsheet
uh this no cross reference here we got a
vlookup going on hopping on different
food joints
trying to see i've never actually had
faux
i need i apparently have been told no
[ __ ] yeah sorry
to the last boom podcast with ebonitis
and cognition
the last spoon ebonitus incognitus
the last spoonies
cocktails uh it gets busy
that we and we in simpatico there yeah i
can
i can do some mixed cocktails now i'm
one of those like i'm the guy who
doesn't like whiskey so
uh but like tequila um mixed drinks
would probably be with vodka but
honestly if it's like tequila
whether it be a shot a margarita
probably in that realm
i will also i make a damn good lemon
drop martini i could drink that until
i'm just on the floor
so alcohol is no restrictions for me
i like everything the only thing i
probably don't like is
you know what's funny i'm not really a
beer guy as much as everybody else
i don't i
the most you'll get me to try is like a
blue moon and even that i don't
don't really care for it uh yeah i've
tried enough between like here's an ipa
it's like okay now i just taste
straight hops or it's like or bud lights
just like this is sparkling kind of piss
water
like i mean like beer i've tried like
some people are like beer
like beer snobs and ipas and all like
the you know craft beers i'm like
totally cool i tried one that was like
had flavor and like whether it was like
chocolate or vanilla and almost like
there was something going on i was like
i could see how you could like that like
that one wasn't terrible but if i'm
gonna choose to drink
i don't it will never be beer first
that's not gonna be
i have a choice it would be number one
risky
number two would be a mojito ah nice i
like the balance
i like the balance i like whiskey like
is it like whiskey just like
neat whiskey water soda whiskey and coke
and meat general generally it can be a
little bit strong but i prefer it neat
because i feel like jack and coke
but it why does it jump too much okay
okay
okay i'll do that i call that man i see
you guys see uh
honeyjack in near long island london
that's not basic
long island is strong bro that is that
is sir i like long island
it's a mask to get you hammered in one
glass that's the point
all right i've done that before
fireball's cool
like i said the only alcohol mystery i
don't i
do not like jaeger i have horror stories
of jaeger
oh my wife doesn't drink that anymore
because of stories
i'll end up somewhere
so you don't control yourself why is it
about
is it because everybody does jager and
red bull together and then they just go
bonkers all night i don't know
even black licorice tasting drink oh see
that's just gross i don't
yeah no i mean i've had a jager in red
bull just cause like they
they did like a group shot and i just
like i can take a shot of most things
you know just to get it done with at
least i can take a shot fast
i will say there are some people who can
take shots which i can take a shot
there are some people who struggle
taking shots at man that is painful to
watch
yeah some some people can't um
but yeah generally it's like i don't
even during this quarantine somebody's
like all the like parents and stuff like
drink like buying out the liquor stores
and stuff
i don't drink much so if i do i want it
to taste good
especially especially at my age i don't
care to like try and get wasted anymore
i'm not trying to party yet
clowns yes amaretto yes daniel
jack daniels honey is oh i'm with you
bro yeah i see what you at
me and dana would vibe i like animals
drink choices amaretto sour
that i can that's like dessert by the
way an amaretto sour is literally like
candy
candy some stuff is like candy to me
like it's very
dangerous for me to have because it
tastes like you'll never get drunk on an
amarado sour but yeah it's just all
sugar that's why
but absolutely absolutely okay this has
definitely gone off the deep end
in spirits at the last one yeah
so we covered top light we saw cognito's
travel through the journey of all ign
podcasts in one week
quite the run through sir need to need
you need you to be running through the
ign office with your like olympic coach
be like i'm here all right next stop i'm
over here alright i'm running out the
door i'll see you guys i gotta go to the
last word tomorrow
then we talked about stasis and now i've
been talking about my picky eating
habits and then we're gonna get drunk at
10 30 in the morning
clearly that's a last word podcast if
i've ever seen one
it's a good one well man it has been
awesome to have you this morning
sorry we went long but i think the end
might have been worth it
um but yeah it's been an absolute
pleasure very cool to get somebody of
your just
knowledge and kind of depth in the
community and everything in here glad we
made it work as well
been trying to make some of our guests
work and you were one that was like come
on we gotta get the timing right so we
got it going good
um but let everybody know where to find
you where to find you on twitter
raidsecrets what do you got doing if
there's anything you're working on on
the side
floor is basically yours so tell
everybody where to find you because
you're going to be heard in
a couple different places uh you can
find me on
twitter.com at hoplitedestiny
on twitch over at the hoplite
um and
keep an eye on socials we are launching
something pretty soon
with myself a son of nomad
and it's going to be fun
okay okay looking forward to it looking
forward to what's going to say that's a
good crew right there
a really good crew
that's quite a stack
i don't know if that's like a stream
team or something not gonna call it too
soon but that's definitely a group
that's awesome um very cool so yeah
definitely watch
follow this lady on twitter follow her
on twitch
if you go to raid secrets remember she's
keeping that thing alive as well so
i definitely thank you for all the work
that you do
and just thank you for being just an
amazing person in this community
it's it's very good to have positive
uplifting supportive people
in a place that sometimes has its
toxicity to it maybe not the best
choices
nice to have some shining lights in
there somewhere
cognito sir i don't know if you can top
what's already happened this week but
what do you got coming up
it's just downhill from here man sorry
yeah this is a week to refer salute to
hoplite for coming through
you know glad we was able to work it out
have some fun talk some destiny
so that that's always amazing but uh
yeah like i said event for a week um
obviously if you didn't get a chance to
catch it um i was on a podcast unlocked
i believe on tuesday i'm losing track of
days and so
you know yesterday i was a fire team
chat a lot of fun with with both teams
salute
had a great time and you know hopefully
back again
and uh yeah you already know man a
little cognito on twitter y'all know
what it is
still regular old cog don't let these
little appearances fool you it's still
me
oh man we got a holly [ __ ] in here now
that's aries he's holly mud he's the
holly modernist of all but you sir
you are the prestigious lord cognateus
with evanitis
yeah man cash you already know um every
sunday the launch day
1 p.m eastern we will be doing islands
podcast no guests this week because
cogni did a break you don't need to do
any intros this week i was very happy to
show up
he had lined up for me i was like
but yeah this sunday we're just gonna
it's gonna be the launch we're gonna
talk about everything that's going down
most likely uh ratchet and clank we're
gonna talk about the great showing that
it had
we're probably talking about the latest
shake up at halo a lot of topics to
discuss
you know so please check us out sunday 1
p.m ireland podcast youtube if you're
not on youtube you catch the uh restream
simultaneous stream
on twitter and um yeah man uh oh thank
you lordsagaming.net man i want to
salute the guys
um we just made open critic
so our reviews will be now aggregated
by an official entity so shout out to
the team
wow yeah like couldn't couldn't get a
bunch of
uh uh better guys that are um you know
committed to writing high quality
writing and we got the application in
so saluted it to team that it really
means a lot we're really gonna do this
up so check us out there
and uh yeah man you already know that
last word
podcast that i had to pub you know even
even though i was with the
shoulders with the hollywood i had to
sleep on the podcast you know what i'm
saying that that's let them know
who we are and that felt good it was
good that he laughed and hit destin but
he remembered you
they knew what was going on and um it's
it's good to see it's good to see people
in the comments section
even if they didn't know me from animal
podcast they knew me from here
and that was dope so salute to eat my
man fun week
and uh looking forward to the future man
this is this is a lot of fun and so
everybody to support y'all in the chat
it's it's been tremendous thank you all
so much it really means a lot to me
well i don't know how i can top these
two so let me bounce this everywhere you
guys can find me
like we got awesome guests come in we
got cognito
having the week of weeks and then yeah
there's me
uh you guys can find me everywhere
twitch twitter youtube
you guys broke 50k still climbing on
that one thank you guys obviously the
next threshold is going to be the 100k
subs so
that'll be you know that's the far
stretch but
i'm halfway i got to work on getting
that button eventually so be doing this
for a little while
uh obviously we'll be breaking down the
stasis trailers for each character
in the next like upcoming week and a
half we'll see what comes from those
uh gonna be playing a little bit of
mortal shell trying to work through that
one
that's a fun one it's not too big so
it's a nice one in between depending on
how much time i get to play
i might work on that one between
avengers coming up so trying to work on
between like balancing my destiny time
for like catalysts and other stuff and
guides there versus
just playing some backlog stuff because
i have so much stuff to work on
that i would like to play like i just
finished goes to sushima
whenever you finish goes to sushima we
have to talk talk i'm
literally on that final oh dude it's
super good
it's so good oh it's so good yeah like
if
i don't want to call the tangent at the
end of the what are y'all playing right
now
uh right now just finish go to sushima
mortal shell if i can beat it this
weekend and avengers coming
but i also have like death stranding
horizon zero dawn and final fantasy vii
in my backlog
definitely recommends something
one of my buddies who i would never
picture liking that
loved it so that's what like he is the
reason i'm gonna play that game at some
point so
and now we got you backing up as well
there's some people that love it some
people
that were like amazon delivery service
but apparently there's something that
game and like the ending of the game i
hear is like four hours so
you gotta strap in and get ready when
you get threaded it's like a two-hour
sequence
yeah wow just cut scenes and no breaks
yeah so it's it's a journey to go
through um
yeah that's typically what are you
playing right now i don't somehow we did
all this and never asked
outside of destiny what are you playing
anything else uh microsoft flight sim
yeah emblem three houses um
a little bit of destiny here may touch
this effect i'm kind of all over the
place
tetris effect is so like that is one if
you just need to like
zen out to go to sleep oh it's amazing
have you played it in vr
uh no i haven't oh that's a whole
different level like it's awesome on
playstation like good sized screen and
everything
you strap into vr in that thing man i
feel like i just like i feel like i took
drugs i know i haven't
i never have but i feel like you're
almost on like
when you start playing and get in sync
with the music and then like a big giant
manta ray swims through your screen i
was like this is fantastic
and it's
my fans yeah
my wife will kick my butt at tetris
forever she will be
she kicks my butt at beat saber and
tetris everything else i got her on
games
i play too many games but the two he
just on a channel bro
yeah my wife's beat saber channel she's
she's a freaking rock star
be like oh here's an expert plus song
like mrs tan on her first try i'm like
but it's not it's not just like hot like
his wife is like
expert level like not like oh she's
okay like this is like how are you doing
this like
you're breaking the game score like if
you're reaching limits that
the game is not ready for you to read
that type of like
really good you're meaning as as a
lifelong gamer i sit there and i'm like
well i am not going to win this battle
you got to cut your losses on some games
and this one
like the learning curve was like hey i
kind of got to like hard
like and then it was just like whoa and
i was like see you
yeah she's she's she's she's a beast
shout out to my wife she'll never listen
to these but shout out to my wife
she doesn't want to listen to two hours
of destiny she's got other stuff to do
i i don't understand
but yeah this has been amazing had a
bunch of fun uh hop you are always
welcome back
um pleasure having you in here glad we
got to see this thing work
we got to wrap this thing up because
holy crap we went longer than i thought
we were going to and i thought we were
ending this thing
um but yeah chat you guys have all been
amazing thank you very much
hang out and chat guys i'm going to send
you guys over to raid somebody once we
are done so hang tight on that one
but today august 28th the day after the
stasis bomb dropped
episode 118 thank you hoplite cog
you got to get some sleep and to all of
you guys thank you very much
it has been the last word